foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
.com's coverage of the Fisher random
World Championship presented by Brave
I'm International Master Lawrence Trent
and I'm delighted to be joined today by
Grandmaster art connections lovely to
see you here all right Lawrence is
absolute pleasure to be here and um I
actually joined in a short notice
because I know everybody is expecting
Robert to join unfortunately he could
not come here uh due to the personal
reasons so either way I mean I think we
are going to have a very very exciting
day ahead and uh yeah should be fun
yeah an upgrade if you ask me no but on
a serious note hopefully not the
downgrade
at least not a downgrade we wish Robert
all the best he's a little bit under the
weather so he will uh he'll be back in
the very near future but today what is
it all about well it's day two of this
world championship it's Fisher random
for all of you who don't know Fisher
random what is it about you've probably
heard of it you might not know what it
is though well it is the chess variant
that was coined even created by the late
great Bobby Fisher where uh you have 960
starting positions and the way it works
is you are able to shuffle all of the
pieces on the back row and you can
actually get 960 different positions by
shuffling those pieces just like in
normal chest white and black is the same
regardless of how those pieces are
shuffled and the standard rules of Chess
apply now uh it's not a format I'm so
familiar with I've played a few games
before Arthur what's your experience
with Fisher random chess
well Lawrence actually I would like to
continue on this thought that all the
standard rules apply I mean not really
because there's this Gosling rule right
and sometimes this is confusing for the
commentators and the viewers alike
sometimes even the players meaning
sometimes castling is done slightly
differently we're used obviously that
Rook comes to the King and King gets
tossed over or I mean actually the right
order should be that the King goes then
The Rook is tossed over but in the chest
960 it's slightly different so as far as
I know the Only Rule is that the King
has to be in the middle of both Rooks
and actually you can make a pretty long
Castle
you can make an extremely long Castle as
long as there is air between the king
and rook and neither pieces moved you
can then Castle so we might get some
weird castling today depending on the
starting position that we'll soon find
out
um let's see how this Championship is
organized so uh the way it works is uh
there are two groups group a in group b
and there are eight players some of the
greatest players in the world including
world champion Magnus Carlson we'll go
into that in a little while two groups
four players in each group and each
match is a double round robin meaning
that you play against your opponent with
white and with black and those are the
mini matches if you win that match you
win two points if the match is a draw
you get one point and of course you win
that match by getting to something like
one and a half points or if you win both
games two points
um
from these group stages the top two of
each group advance to The Knockout stage
of this tournament and the time control
is slightly unusual it's 25 minutes for
each player but after 30 moves each
player is then given five extra minutes
and a five second increment so
theoretically the games can actually go
on for a fairly long time a very very
novel time control but interesting
nonetheless
this is day two Arthur let's take a look
at the standings for group a after
yesterday's day one action and we can
see here live at the top we have got
Nordic abdusatorov on a maximum Four
Points Wesley so and yeah II and the
local Grandmaster good friend of mine
jopy as he's better known
not Off the Mark just yet uh Arthur
Abdul satorov he's not really a let's
say an unknown quantity now in the world
of Chess but does it surprise you that
he's top of the table
um yeah actually I would say it's a bit
surprising I mean of course sub the
sator of strength can't be argued
because not only he's uh one of the
heroes from the past watches Olympiad
you probably all of you remember that
the Uzbekistan sensationally won the
gold medals and also they're going to
host uh the Olympiad in several years
but also he's the reigning world rapid
Champion he's only what 18 right I think
that's actually pretty much incredible
he's been showing his speeches skills
um well before but I mean to dominate
the group just like that to take down
the reigning wolfish random Champion
Wesley so to demolish the world
championship Challenger uh well Jane
pomonishi this is this is really
something unexpected I would have
expected he's definitely going to be a
contender but not only the group after
the first day
yeah exceptional stuff by the 18 year
old Superstar from Uzbekistan I've
spoken to a lot of top players in the
past year or so who say that this kid
well he's already shown he's the real
deal amazing performance of the Olympiad
amazing performance of world rapid
championship and now showing his true
Talent by being able to play chess 960
which let's face it is the ultimate test
of real chest Talent at least that was
the theory proposed by Bobby Fisher
because uh the the the concept is of
course that you eradicate opening Theory
because there are too many positions to
learn opening Theory therefore it's just
how you understand how the pieces work
that allow you to become a great player
so Abdul satoroff really showing the
world that he is a mightily talented
player in group b uh we have got a very
familiar name on top but perhaps a
slight surprise here because it it's not
Magnus Carlson on the top of the table
but rather his
uh let's call it Nemesis in inverted
commas I'm not sure I'm not sure sure
there's so much there's so much uh
um animosity there anymore Hikaru
Nakamura
uh one of the greatest plays of course
in the world he qualified to this
tournament via the open qualifiers
um and he was actually the only place to
defeat Wesley so during the 2019 Fisher
random World Championship he beat Magnus
yesterday Arthur but it was a slightly
strange game which he won yeah I mean
obviously Lawrence we're talking about
the game where Magnus opened with G5 I
think this was one of the uh most
incredible openings in Fisher random
chess I had ever seen I mean it's not
only I mean it's not a mockery it's
completely legit move against Hikaru
where he sacrificed a piece on move one
and it worked and it seemed that Magnus
was controlling the match and uh there
was this huge blunder
where he blundered the rook and as he
explained later after the game he simply
mixed up the word with the most he
played the second move instead of the
first move he dropped the whole rook and
thus lost the match but uh
I mean Magnus is a bit unrecognizable
Lawrence to be honest because he has
made a couple of heavy blunders so far
yeah but I think he still has decent
shots to qualify because once again the
tournament system is that the best two
of every group qualify for The Knockout
stages and they will play each other
once again
absolutely yup he can still get that
circumcision he can still win the
tournament as well theoretically depends
how he does today and let's have a look
at those matches for today because we've
got some interesting uh pair UPS of
course uh or every single day is
interesting there's always going to be a
big Clash
um in group a we've got gretison against
abdisatorov uh and we've got so against
the promising uh our tours I mean
gretison he's not quite being able to
keep Pace with the big boys and given
Abdul satorov's form we can't expect
anything less than a than an order back
clean sweep can we
right I mean for gretelson so far it's
been also pretty difficult because he's
a clear Underdog of the entire
tournament and a wild card of the uh
organizers but uh
I I think he definitely is going to
surprise uh at least in one match one of
the mini matches I mean he has to he's a
very strong romister I'm not sure is it
going to be in this match because of the
satorophy is definitely in a great shape
so I would still probably lean towards
giving up the satoraf as a favorite
status but again let's watch out for
graterson I'm pretty sure he's going to
surprise somebody Wesley so against
Yandy okay this is quite unpredictable
but um probably Wesley has a slight Edge
uh due to his past successes and of
course Magnus Carlsen should be a
favorite against Matthias bluebound and
I also rate Hikaru chances higher than
feather saves
yeah totally agree with you on all of
those matches we can see the players
starting to settle in Magnus Carlson
they're uh playing against Matthias
bluebaum one of Germany's top players
but again big big difference rating wise
around 200 points in normal ELO of
course Matthias is a very very strong
player and in Fisher random uh anything
can happen as we saw yesterday Magnus
making a huge blunder against Hikaru
Nakamura a a a very very unexpected
blunder he also blundered I think
earlier as well in the day so Magnus not
playing at a hundred percent so far
let's see if he regains that form
today and the players are settling in
nicely uh this event of course taking
place in Iceland which is a very
significant for the Fisher random
uh uh World Championship because uh well
of course of Bobby Fisher's links to
Iceland he is buried there we can see on
screen you have a
the local hero one of the top Grand
Masters
otters do you know if um Grand Masters
are still paid a salary in Iceland for
being a Grandmaster
to be honest Lawrence I have no idea no
idea but uh Iceland definitely has
greatest tradition and gretelson has
been the leading Ramos or grammaster for
quite a bit years
uh
right so I understand the games are
about to start it's something like one
minute or less
yeah we've got about a minute left and I
want to make sure that
right so I guess they're waiting for a
ceremonial move well let's hope nobody
plays G4
well we don't know so the beautiful
thing of course about uh Fisher random
is that when the pieces are set up and
we will get a clear view of how how the
pieces are set up today and we can see
the ceremonial move taking place there
because the piece is all set up in a
random way a move like G4 could actually
be the best move so it's not normal
chess it's not we're not playing the
grob opening it just depends on how the
pieces are set up and we're going to get
those pieces and that looks like E4 from
the side artists in this blue bomb game
which is very interesting uh right
so let's let's maybe start with Marcus's
game uh yeah
so here we go E4 is on the board
sticking to the proven values I guess
right I mean comfy mistake we have seen
a fair share of different openings uh
one thing Lawrence you know I tell you
honestly I don't know much about the
opening Theory I have pretty much
limited experience in just 960 which
maybe I'm gonna mention after a while
but one thing I noticed is that at least
at the club level exactly F6 I can't
Capital feel it's very easy to miss a
pawn for example on A2 right I've seen a
fair share of very funny stories I mean
somebody plays very quickly the first
one then blunders and Therapies
yeah absolutely uh you can blunder a
piece you can blunder a pawn a little
move like F6 uh allowing the queen to to
attack a weak pawn and I think that's
what the top players do when they study
the starting position the elected
starting position they look for the
unprotected spots so Magnus already had
A2 uh as as as a kind of key
porn to attack
um and uh Blue Bombers replied Knight B3
protecting that pawn so curious to see
what Magnus does in this position
obviously tons of moves and all kinds of
ideas available
uh shall we look at uh another game as
well to see if there's been any other
uh interesting openings from this
starting position
um absolutely we can do that maybe we
can switch to the game of here we go
just a second the Wesley so against Jana
permission actually Lawrence I have a
question to you yes I do understand you
have also some experience in chess 960
right it's not like completely blank you
have play just 960. I've played it
before yes right so now I have a
question to you so okay do you do you do
you try to improvise like going
completely crazy outsmart your opponent
or you're like doing the most of us try
to get a normal position as quickly as
possible what do you do yeah uh yeah I
I'm not strong enough to improvise so I
try to just get a normal position make
moves that look sensible I don't try to
win out of the opening uh I unless you
know there's a clear a clear Target so
for example what's happened in Wesley's
game is exactly the sort of way I would
play bring my Knights out towards the
center same rules apply the knights are
going to be useful uh not on the edge
but towards the center but my Pawns in
the center and
you you can still apply
traditional chess rules or traditional
chess guidelines to some 960 positions
so
that's how I approach it but again I'm
very very inexperienced
right this is I think uh at the
subconscious level everybody is trying
to do at least most of the players
perhaps the best of the players in the
world try to get the normal position as
quickly as possible and why it is
because we have been trained to
recognize certain positions certain
patterns certain Pawn structures and
then we can play it faster but when you
have something like this when every
single piece is obviously
misplaced where it's not supposed to be
it's quite difficult and that's why I
think the best players in the world they
are like trying immediately to trick the
opponent from the very first moves and
get an advantage
yeah and also the other thing about
Chess 960 which is very interesting to
me is that oh do I I'll call it Fisher
random chess because that's the the name
of this tournament is that um
the difference between black being white
and black doesn't feel as great when we
play a normal game of chess in a
classical game where black our objective
is to try and
equalize out of the opening but I I feel
like I want to be ambitious with black
in in Fisher random chess do you get the
same feeling
right yeah yeah I definitely I do right
so um
um actually here looking at this
position I noticed that the black just
played G6 which is pretty tricky do we
understand it is that
black is trying to limit this Knight on
G3 right so that at least makes sense
I'm not really sure if the bishop H6 was
the big idea
and then he plays yeah
yeah but it all it already looks like a
position where I don't like what black
is doing for example even if I just play
D5 here as white to try to gain some
space and then even I could follow up
with C4 looks very very passive okay you
can always throw in the check but I can
block with Bishop T2 I don't think the
trade of dark squared Bishops is is such
a big issue
and remember why can still Castle right
on right Queen side
on the queen side how actually would
that look like yeah I'm I'm trying to
work that out because I'm a bit confused
with this configuration of the Rooks
even I'm slightly confused and on the
but on the king's side he probably can't
in this configuration on the king side
obviously you need to remove these
pieces and then just short Castle King
goes to G1 root ghost on F1 but if the
long side Castle I guess the Rook simply
gets tossed over and this Rook needs to
go go somewhere I don't know where to be
honest I mean maybe not just yet
on that
it looks pretty weird I mean what can I
say
it's a bit it's a bit strange here
because we you can't have two Rooks
occupying the same square so we will get
clarification on on how that uh Castle's
long would work but I'm not impressed in
general with napometry's opening
um so I think Wesley uh will be very
very happy so far with how things are
going
and I think he's got a nice nice
position already
um there's been a lot of moves in the
Nakamura game all right perhaps we can
go there yeah let's let's move
um
okay here we go
um same same problem with the with a
white king or The Rook on B1 still white
can't uh easily make a castle so can we
make our first conclusions from the
position is that white has slightly
better light Square Bishop if that even
matters at all I guess it doesn't
um
yeah difficult difficult one to say uh I
I prefer white in this position just
because
uh you know the light squared Bishop is
arguably slightly better but I don't
think it's much I I for example compared
to the Wesley so game I think uh feder
save is is doing very well and I just
want to
um just to clarify something about
castles so for example let's say Artur
the bishop on F1 moved to E2 and the
queen moved to F2 so the back rank was
completely clear in this game all right
why could then Castle kingside so the
king would move to G1 and the D1 Rook
would move to F1
so is that a short cast is that a long
Castle
well it's a it's a short Castle
on the king side but it's quite a long
one but yes it's an interesting
difficult yeah that's a funny funny
funny way to describe it but that's how
white would Castle
um in this position so I'm curious to
see if we will actually get that we
think it actually makes perfect sense
yes but you can't Castle right in order
to get some attacking chances I think
one of the uh best practices at least at
the competitive chess is you want to
position the King on the other side of
the board than your opponent's king so
that you can just push for those Pawns
in front of the blacking but again I
mean you have to also think that black
and essentially do the same right I
think black also is entitled to the to
the short long cast or long short cast
or whatever you call it I mean play 96
Bishop seven and there you go yeah and
actually I think it's one of the most
dangerous moves in chess 960 because you
forget that it's available sometimes and
suddenly you're attacking this King on
the queen side and it just runs to the
to the other side of the board and you
feel a little silly
um so we'll see if that happens let's
move to another game let's go to the
leader of the group a playing against
the Local Hero gret arson we've got uh
grandson against Abdul satorov
and it's already you know compared to
some of the other positions
I I have to say I like black setup much
more here compared to for example the
um the setup that nepomishi has against
sir
um right
again it's uh quite difficult uh to
understand let's say what exactly is
going on here but with G5 I guess black
is following the strategy that you want
to push those pawns as far as you can to
gain more space for your Bishops
and I really like how oftenator office
improvising right at the start also
after G5 maybe ideas like Knight G6
become an option to fight for the
squares on F4 and H4
then decide where to put the doc's web
Bishop
you know Lawrence I'm not really sure
how at this level goes the preparation
at just 96 I'm pretty sure they have
studied something it's not like they
turn up to the world Fisher random
championship and they're completely
blank they have no ideas the best
players in the world I'm pretty sure
they recognize some patterns some ideas
some structures for example let's say
when you have the Knight on A1 or you
have the bishop on G1 Bishop H1 I've
seen that sometimes they're playing
pretty much the same way so is there
some opening Theory or it's just me
um I think you're absolutely right I
think there are some general ideas about
how to approach 960. I think the real
die-hard uh Fisher random 960. I'm going
to use those terms interchangeably just
for everybody watching uh all the all of
the Die Hard fans that play this or
watch it have actually learned some
theory in some of the positions but I
think you're absolutely right just for
these guys who don't play it all the
time they just have an idea about
general concepts and there's absolutely
no way that they're going into this
tournament unprepared so
yeah so uh it would be an interesting
question to actually ask them and get
get interviewed about
um in this particular position after D4
I mean things are still very very close
aren't they here uh you know I liked F5
and I do like D4 as well bye
grandson Knight F7 and now again what do
you do here is why do you bring your
pieces in Bishop G2 Knight F2 makes
sense
um yeah it's a fight for the space as I
understand it right so here white lady
Ford open the best pawn G3 and black
says no I'm not gonna open your bishop
and instead I'm gonna bring my knight in
the game and I guess after something
like d-days ideas like 95 appear on the
horizon and I'm pretty sure that
gretelson is not gonna trade his docs
were Bishop just like that but he might
have some problems with this Knight
because now Lawrence look at this
position I have a feeling that the Black
Knight on F7 uh due to his can I call it
slight Miner space Advantage he has
easier route to join the game because
this night let's say it goes to F2 black
and just play E4 how do you bring it in
the game and he plays it yeah yeah he
does he does play it and I do like E4 I
think E4 is is a very support moves you
gain that space the Knight on F2 becomes
yucky and black can then continue with
all kinds of he's got the C4 Square he's
got breaks he's got levers on either
side of the board H5 A5 all come to mind
at the right moment so I do like E4 and
I think black is in the driving seat
here I like this position a lot
yeah I also would choose a black sided
cause after E4 now if white wants to
activate this Knight on F2 it has to be
something like 91 93 although black also
has some weakness here on E6 and needs
to watch out for Knight c596
I mean the game is still a complete mess
far from normal so maybe once again we
make a full turn around and go back to
the world champions game Lawrence what
do you think
yeah absolutely and what we could do is
uh we could actually uh have a bird's
eye view of all four boards
uh if uh you like there you go look at
that
all four games going on at the same time
tons of moves played in Wesley so uh
against Jan the pomnishi which is
uh not totally unexpected yeah and the
published extremely fast player doesn't
matter if he's playing classical Blitz
Fisher random doesn't matter at all the
slowest game so far is actually blue
bomb against Carlson those guys uh yeah
I mean they're thinking is really really
slow right taking it very very slowly
indeed although I do like magnus's uh
position he's managed to trade and
centralizes queen which is which is
interesting but in the other game the
Wesley soap game it looks as though he's
got a fantastic position there uh with
uh with a knight posted on C5 that space
Advantage Jana probably she has castled
so he has castled on the king side
but uh so that's the long short Castle
whatever you call it indeed the launch
exactly I think we are going to see it
once more right because it's just so
much fun to make it
yeah you just play it because it's you
can't normally do it it's personal
points right it's really for style
points right I mean you play G5 for the
first move like Magnus yesterday play
against Hikaru maybe it's not the best
movie you just played for the style
point so the people notice it I mean
you're you're an artist you want to
create something amazing
absolutely
um should we go to that Carlson game
because actually
uh we we've had an important moment uh
uh here and sorry was blue bum with
black I beg your pardon blue balm was
with black and Magnus has just now
played what looks like a very critical
move the move pawns are D4 trying to
open up the position with the queen
slightly
um exposed let's say on D5 but blue bomb
just says I'm not worried
if you play D takes E5 I will play Queen
takes D1 mate which is the sort of mate
you could fall for playing online
because you just expect the Rooks to be
connected but they are not connected
here so what to do is white maybe you
play Knight F2 threatening
do you take C5 that's maybe the way
right I guess you need to include this
Knight and the game as quickly as
possible but then again you play
something like neither too what about
the queen right so it's not only uh
including one piece in the game you have
to think about the entire picture and
obviously in in the classical jazz
position as we know it it's easier
because we have been trained we've
recognize it but here
it's easy to forget it's easy to forget
about one of the pieces and I think
that's also the reason why so many games
are decisive because one of the players
completely misplaced the opening it's
like -2 or plus two in the computer
language that's completely winning for
the other player uh there's no solid
shots it's just pure inspiration
yeah that does happen now I do want to
point out apologies I thought I was
going insane I'm not slight technical
glitch uh Magnus is black he's not white
in this game so it's blue balm now who
just played the move Bishop B2
and it's magnus's move and now the
question is
is D takes E5 some kind of a threat
maybe not even such a big threat but I
expect Magnus to move the queen
uh and he doesn't he plays the move
Knights of G6
um no G6 it actually makes sense of
course because the knights on the edge
of the board as far as we know they're
not misplaced because uh they I usually
call them half a knight really because
they don't operate on the other uh lines
which simply don't exist so Knight G6
makes sense also previously by Magnus
Knight B6 was to be played Knight F4
appears to be an idea and I can't help
but feel that something is going
slightly wrong for the German gramister
because his pieces are look a bit
awkward the bishoponi to the bishopony
one the bishpanito is not really doing
anything if white includes the knight in
the game something like Knight afterward
Knight G3 what about the queen while
magnus's Bishops on E at nf8 they just
look awesome
yeah uh
I'm starting to like Black's position a
little more I didn't like Bishop B2
feels a little bit passive by Matthias
but I don't think the position is out of
control just yet uh but
we'll see
um let's move on and let's go to
gretasan against Abdu setorov because uh
this game yeah this game is really
heating up
what have we got going on here all of
this tension in the center we might have
to calculate something now
um E3 it made me really curious there
you go so it was Knight C4 played E4 now
you can't take on e4 because the bishop
is under attack so what allowed Knight
E3 to be played on rookie one
exactly visually I like it for white
feels as though that the trades are
profitable for white because the center
white is a little bit more uh developed
somehow so the center is is dissolving
in White's favor so for example if
Knight takes F1 uh Queen takes F1
um
um yeah and I guess the point is yeah if
ed4 now you actually have some yeah
Knight d4s of course
the main movement tonight has got a
beautiful outpost on E6 and if you play
the other way D takes E4 then after
Knight takes you for the F6 Pawn
uh is very very limp and suddenly the
structure is actually starting to to
fall apart here for blacks this is
actually a bride no this is a bit
dangerous for black is it not it it
definitely looks like that Lawrence
because I have a feeling that uh when we
go back a couple of months here maybe
Knight C4 was uh with good intentions
obviously because you spot a weakness on
E3 and at your subconscious knowledge uh
your subconscious mind you think that
white should somehow keep an eye on the
Square and maybe play something like 93
Etc and there you go boom ratherson
suddenly plays E4
and says I don't care about weakness on
E3 and after 93 rookie one as you
already pointed it out Lawrence I I
really like how White's Knights are
positioned so it's quite amazing how the
violation of the position from slightly
better for black to just much better for
white can change so quickly in just 960.
yeah that's that's one of the things I
have noticed is that there is a there is
a big swing a lot of the time in in the
positions uh
compared to normal let's say super Grand
Master chess where things can be quite
level for a long time we can see the bar
really go like a like a like a heartbeat
uh Monitor and yeah Knight takes F1
played uh Queen takes F1 will be played
by Granderson and a five by Abdullah of
who is clearly saying I need to be quick
and Urgent here but this looks
incredibly optimistic ed5a4 really
do you believe this
actually you know Lawrence I would have
to go back to this moment here A5 is
actually a pawn sacrifice right it's a
great idea without the Rook uh Knight A5
Rook A8 something black activates the
rook and white spot on NATO also is
indirectly under attack so here that's
why greterson took on D5 and clearly is
eyeing for 95.96 which
were just played so I'm not really sure
uh
if black is happy I guess he is Bishop
C5 and Rook D5 probably is going to be
played
yeah he he it looks as though that that
wasn't good so the bar fluctuated let's
just go back there because did white
have something unbelievable because the
bar at the moment is just really in
White's favor so it's 85 A4 is there
anything here Knight C5 is of course the
the human move
I mean we could of course discuss maybe
not if I was a move not F5 rookie yet
and then played some crazy contenation
like B4 but to be honest
I kind of don't believe it yeah neither
does the bar
let's get a little ridiculous I guess
because of B6 or something
but I mean even in in the game position
uh it looks as though after Rook 65 I
mean yopi is gonna play uh Knight E4
here this is just a move you play you
protect C5 you threaten Knight takes F6
and what is the evaluation there 94 you
actually have to defend this poor no
with a move like Queen G7 I don't think
you can allow Knight takes F6
probably not unless of course of the
satorok has some Dynamic response in his
mind Queen G7 is something you don't
want to play because it sort of shuts
out the queen but he might simply have
to do it and uh answering the question
who is uh not who is but how to properly
evaluate this position I think it's
pretty obvious that it's white who is
better mainly I guess because of the
Knight on e4 this weakness on F6 so
black is probably wishing to play Bishop
C6 or Rook D4 as follow as quickly as
possible and get rid of this Knight so
the fact that white has these double
pawns I guess it doesn't really play a
role right now
yeah and these double pawns can also be
very useful I mean the pawn on C5 is an
extremely important problem because it
prevents Knight D6 which is a move that
black would sometimes like to play
indeed Queen G7 on the board and now the
question is how to uh
uh Advance here with white there are a
lot of moves that come to mind as white
uh one move
interesting movies maybe to play B4 now
now that the queen has left the A2 to G8
diagonal we can try B4 and there's a lot
of things yeah and if a takes B3 we just
go a takes B3 I don't think we want to
take with the c Pawn we now give a nice
Square on B2 for our King to just slide
into we could then challenge for the D5
Rook A1 or Rook D1 maybe challenge for
the D file uh White's pieces nicely
centralized and blacks pieces just not
really working probably black has to put
a bishop on C6 remove the rook and try
and make something happen but you take
white here all day long surely
right and now also it looks that the
black ink is perhaps slightly more
vulnerable on C8 because the option to
cast long unfortunately for Black is
gone and maybe this is something he
would have actually wished wish to have
at some point
uh yeah before it looks uh pretty good I
don't think that castling long please
correct me Laura's is it legal probably
it's not I think no no I think it is
legal now are you sure I'm pretty I
think so and that's legal yeah yeah it
actually doesn't cross the default right
yeah you can Castle yes yes because your
king doesn't walk through check so you
you can Castle long here Castle's long
probably is actually a move isn't it now
that I think of it it's definitely a
move yeah yeah so Bishop C6 maybe to
follow on black actually can also do the
same Toss The Rook over to B8
so this is one of the things that I
actually long Castle has been played
this is one of the things that I really
adore is that um at a good level you
just treat costling as a move it's not a
requirement I mean why do we even castle
at all we Castle first to bring the king
to the safety and second to connect the
Rooks and that's it and sometimes the
king is just standing well enough in the
center wherever it was so actually I'm
not so sure that this long Castle
Lawrence was so good and I liked your B4
a bit more
yeah and actually uh this has been all
right because now with Black's last move
of course black is trying to reduce the
material because of the opposite colored
Bishops and the problem white has got
now is that Bishop C6 comes versus
anything and the Knight doesn't have a
stable condition on e4 the Knight will
move or black will have the opportunity
to trade and I feel as though black is
over the worst air so I think uh also
Gritz assemble he was probably
very uh sort of uh
artistically in enthused by this move
castles because it's it's such a rare
move to me but uh actually objectively
it doesn't look like it's that
impressive and Abu satorov I think is
all right should we yes should we move
on to uh to another game and where do
you want to go I'll let you choose maybe
let's check that amazing game that
Wesley has he had this beautiful night
on C5 now he adds more to The Possession
by adding also the Knight on G5 uh and
as far as I'm concerned Lawrence he
still hasn't Castle while Jan did Castle
short long long short side of whatever
you call it but Wesley's King is still
on C1 and after 95 he's clearly eyeing
for 96 this is a very juicy outpost on
E6 and that's why young plays Queenie
seven but what about the white king
slightly vulnerable no
well you can always Castle
forgot about that you can always and
there you go
you could just Castle kingside no
problems at all connect the Rooks put
the King on a safe Square uh you love to
see it uh it's just amazing yeah yeah
it's a great move and now it's very
obvious that white has a solid Advantage
because of these beautiful Knights the
weakness on E6 is there so nepomishi is
trying to salvage the position but this
is already getting some sort of a normal
position that the players are aiming for
kings are where they're supposed to be
and Black's weaknesses are pretty
obvious
yeah Wesley has to be very very happy
with this position
um
you know the E5 Pawn
looks very vulnerable to me as you said
the Knight of course landing on E6
and these positions aren't Yan's
favorites to to defend that's for sure
so Wesley in in a comfortable position
here and another comfortable position
looks as though it's for the world
champion Magnus Carlson playing against
the rating Underdog Matthias bluebaum
let's go there otters and this is just
uh a case of in my period in my opinion
Matthias has played very little chess
960 Fisher random Magnus played a lot
more and
two Bishops
right and I've if my golf lessons are
correct then the black is technically
down a pawn right so oh yes sacrifice
it looks as though black is down a pawn
let's see so yeah so that was this
sequence we missed after 96 dx25 Knight
F4 Magnus once again goes for the style
points he sacrificed the queen
Rook d592 I think this actually is
already clear
application for the move of the round
Lawrence right I mean one of them
Absolute moves so far yeah so for sure
and there you go look at this I mean
average players you see like oh there's
a pawn in E5 why don't we take it right
but then Magnus shows it's more than
pawns so you just try the Queens
make a long Castle what about this
sequence Carlson's Queen side check love
it and Bishop is just amazing it's just
amazing I mean I just love the sequence
so this once again shows the amazing
understanding that the world champion
cast that he clearly more than anybody
else in the world knows the importance
of Peace activities so sacrificing the
pawn just to get uh a lot of activity
for Magnus this is piece of cake
yeah and white suffering Bishop takes C2
is a massive threat the Knight on H1 has
yet to get into the game
um if you play something like Rook C1
which is
uh you know possible it's better than
Knight A1 definitely I think
but now you run into all kinds of stuff
right so
if it feels I mean in the worst case you
play f t C5 but I feel as though we
we've got something better maybe not
Knight A4 is a move Knight D5 I thought
was also interesting
uh to be able to play Knight F4 check
in some positions but maybe not so
precise
um
yeah and it looks a certain position on
the board is actually very very
different I think we do have some moves
here
because it went up yeah he took on F6
he took on F6 I guess he tries to
clarify the position and then now he
simply has to acknowledge that he is
worse I mean black as the bishop pair
the Knight on H1
is just one sad night
it is it's not going to stay there
forever though I mean what why I mean
blue bomb here is going to play King G1
there's just no question about it to be
able to then prepare Bishop G3 and
Knight F2 this is the the classic way to
to get his pieces out I mean you have to
play King G1 here and Lawrence we have
an update there is the first result the
first result so Hikaru Nakamura if you
go very quickly to this position
kikarnakamura against Vladimir for the
safe
they didn't find anything really
exciting in this game they got a normal
position as quickly as possible pieces
disappear from the board Rooks Queens
nice probably so this was drug read both
sides got Mutual weaknesses on E4 E5
that's why they decided
to call it quits and uh they're gonna
wait for the next game so do we go back
to the Magnus against I think we go I
think we go back there because it did
Matthias actually play no he went Knight
G3 immediately which is
interesting but now after Knight A4 it's
precisely
uh
and is that correct that Matthias is
down to two minutes
I mean that's what it looks like
Magnus playing extremely fast and they
are only on move 17.
no additional time until move 31 so blue
balm under tremendous time pressure
already he might not make it uh he's
just getting slowly outplayed
Magnus doing Magnus things
um
it's hard to play against Michael skulls
and what can I tell you he's not an easy
opponent and definitely definitely he's
not and uh now I think that Matthias uh
he knows he knows that he's in big
trouble he's not happy the way he played
it so big part of just of course it's
psychology and I think his body language
he is mimics it says it all right he
knows he he has to make this ugly move
Bishop C3 he knows he's going to be
tortured for God knows how many moves
but it is what it is it is what it is of
course he's not very happy but you know
Matthias also is of course a very strong
ramaster if I'm not totally wrong
reigning uh European individual
individual Champion right as far as I my
memory is not totally wrong yes he he
won the European championship
uh last year but I mean of course
playing against Magnus it's an entirely
different challenge
yeah it's it's a different world uh
playing against the Norwegian and the
two Bishops here really do
decide who has got the advantage
um not easy though still conversion
technique required here materials down
to one minute
33 seconds and he's got to make about 10
moves F5 Knight ec5 on the board now A
Move Like Bishop G7 looks incredibly
logical hitting the Rook with Tempo
um
something like Rook C2 can happen now
there is a 96 red but no you could even
go F4 exactly I love this move you hit
the timber again
I'm looking if there's some forced
material win I just can't make it work
immediately but these Bishops together
they just make a wonderful impression
yeah this is just right you can never
just say slowly
also looks pretty good Lawrence right I
mean although there's this Rook E7
threat but Bishop five uh you want to
play B6 next and I have a feeling that
the best probably white candle at some
point is give up the pawn on B2 right I
mean just play 96 takes takes give up
the pawn on B2 and just pray you know
what else to do here but blacks two
connected past pawns eventually somehow
should the side effect again in favor
for black I'm a big fan of the Bishops
what can I say
yeah absolutely
okay
he did Play Bishop seven King E2
22 22 moves have been played so clearly
blue bomb is an intense stump pressure
here
yeah and he's shaking he's been shaking
his head for the past five ten five ten
minutes he understands the position is
just very bad Magnus will just play B6
here I'm pretty sure just to kick the
Knight because well Knight A6 you go C5
so B6 played Knight E3 a magnesia will
probably just play C5 anyway
um
right so CPAP I think it clearly limits
white Knight's possibilities to jump
also it brings on the table some ideas
like C5 C4 black can always play C5 King
B7 A5 A4 these pawns On A to B to their
juicy targets so black is gonna have
really time of the life uh going after
them and uh I think I think Lawrence
this game is uh
Magnus is gonna do it
yeah King B7 instead Magnus choosing the
slow route absolutely no reason why not
and now he might even just play he I
don't I don't want to go C5 now it feels
a little loot you can go A5 you can go
um rookie 8 check it doesn't look
ridiculous to me
um and this is a trap right Bishop A2 I
don't think it's possible due to the B3
B3 yeah he's not taking it he's not
taking the Fisher spasky Pawn the irony
of taking this Pawn in this
tournaments actually Lawrence I mean uh
yes in the famous Fishers basket Match
Game one was it right I mean Bishop
takes on H2O was played by uh Fisher and
then 50 years later somebody else plays
in Iceland Bishop takes an A2 and traps
the bishop yeah exactly
it would be a nice story but Magnus
coasting here he's gonna play he's gonna
play A5 or C5 or a rook E3
also bluebound 42 seconds he's got to
make about five moves
uh
and yeah if he goes
so now
he probably has to go Knight C1 right to
defend this
but this is the movie you simply don't
want to make because you play Knight C1
and I don't see why I might as well just
stay until the end of the game but of
course in order to keep the pawn and A2
alive Knight C1 is blade and again blow
up is shaking the head I mean he's so
uncappy we know we know him at the yes
you're unhappy
uh 20 seconds on the clock and uh move
26 once again extra time was after move
30 right 31. 30 31 so he's gonna make it
he's he's too he's too good not to make
it
uh he should I mean
Magnus will now just slowly uh improve
C5 H5
looked like moves A5
um
one of these porn moves I believe will
be played
um The Rook on E3 is not doing very much
either so he might just come back with
the Rook
uh let's see but Matthias has got to
play quickly
otherwise he's going to lose
on it's
time it's funny Lawrence you know I just
read in the in the chat that people say
that Matthias is bad at the poker face
but to be honest talking about poker
faces you know I think there is a
there's an uh a good idea to make a
so-called Poker Face I mean not
hiding your uh
uh emotional feeling yeah you know yeah
exactly your feelings uh you are hiding
it when you don't want to disclose right
but but I think this is not the case
right so obviously Magnus knows that
he's the one who is pushing he knows
that he's Bishops are far superior and
uh the so-called poker face it's more
common when you like when you make a
blunder and you realize you made a
blunder but maybe your opponent has not
and actually I just recall this very
famous episode of 2013 World
Championship Match Carlson against Anand
game six right when Magnus made this
terrific blunder King D1 instead of King
D2 I think it was King D1 instead of
King D2 whatever and uh he made a very
very big blunder I think he realized it
pretty quick and as soon as Anan didn't
notice it and responded with something
else Magnus just collapsed on the board
so that means no time uh there's no need
for the poker face anymore and of course
I think also for avishi it was pretty
obvious that he missed and while I was
talking about poker faces yes there's an
exchange
yeah he he sacrifices I mean Mateus
trying a cute little idea he wants to
play King D2 and trap The Rook on C3 but
can we just go C4 here as Magnus
King D2 and in the worst case scenario
in the worst case scenario play Rook
takes C1 King takes C1 C takes B3 and
that ending with the two connected past
pawns no no C4 uh artists yeah
so if you go C4 King D2
Rook takes C1 King takes C1 C takes P3
e6b3 I don't really see a better move
yeah I think this is this is a win this
should be a win I I don't see how black
can ever uh Kaw white can ever save this
and uh after Knight F1 no Magnus is uh
choosing five seconds on the clock one
or two moves to be played for white it
doesn't matter but still I think it's
pretty cool idea that blue bomb came up
it just doesn't work yeah
no a very very cool idea uh actually and
uh you know fair play to Blue balm
because he you know he tries to find a
resource in a position that is very very
ugly
but Magnus will find this or he'll he'll
find another idea he's got a lot of time
on the clock
and blue balm
I mean blue bomb is going to make the
bonus time
for sure but his position is just not
not good enough also like another move
like you could go B5 King D2
B4
92 and now even Bishop takes B3 might be
winning for black I think it's a little
bit more convoluted well otherwise we
lose the whole exchange if Knight takes
C3 B takes E3 check and Bishop takes A2
feels like a worse version because the
pawns are disconnected uh and if you
play instead a takes B3
uh you
and after Rook takes B3 uh three
connected pass pawns and The Rook it's
going to be too much uh in real terms so
looks as though Magnus is is winning and
another player that looks like he's got
a great position
is the leader of group a let's also go
there gretelson against after satorov
or we did see a move actually from
Magnus where did he go
yeah he did play your C4 so I think he
just evaluated that he has no other
choices and this is looks looking a
technical win and pretty sure that
Magnus is going to do it so you're right
let's let's jump to the leader
um
and uh
that's an extra exchange right the best
point G8 is looking towards the pawn on
A2 so why it's only chance try to
salvage the game is the Pawn on H6 but
the bishop on G8
is wait wait wait
so there's not F6 and there's also the G
Pawn running
exactly and the Knight actually blocks
the the check on the back rank it's a
very cute position but looks as though
that just doesn't hold ever
without the G Pawn I would actually say
that white is doing really much all
right because of this Knight F6 is being
such a monster threat but probably the G
Pawn is going to decide the effect of
the game for blackened it's also
confirmed by the bar
um
this is potentially one passport for
black this is potentially another
passport for black and I don't think the
white king can do it and
most likely what will try to run towards
the G Pawn to stop it
and then somehow keep his chances alive
with the threat of Knight G5 Knight F6
get rid of the bishop so that he can
promote his own point but I don't think
this is going to happen
yeah this looks looks bad for
feel for happy and
the uh the form player in the world
actually I would say Abdu satorov uh
possibly has a claim for best player of
the year 2022 it's between him uh gukesh
irigasi
um but really those three uh have been
the standout players for me this year uh
he is he's going to win this position
Bishop H7 also a nasty move because you
can now take on C2 with check
um and then I think this does it yeah
this does it yeah yeah you do you take
on C2 you take the pawn on H4 so this
Pawn is not going anywhere black is
going to bring the king claws so the
pawn and NATO has a weakness is not
going anywhere so Bishop H7 very very
precise mobile so this means that uh he
is uh stepping closer to win the match
because once again to remind the format
of the tournament they're playing mini
matches right Lawrence it's two games in
every single mini match and scoring the
victory with a black color obviously is
a huge step winning another mini match
yeah exactly uh two games uh so you know
Magnus if he wins which I think he will
and uh blue balm I mean he's gonna try
and put up a bit of resistance here but
unsuccessfully uh uh two games you win
that and then they play each other again
so it's a bit different compared to
yesterday so there will be another two
game mini match between blue balm and
Magnus of course this match isn't over
yet blue bands still can if Magnus wins
today blue balm can still win uh with
the uh with the black pieces but here's
odds of saving this game are looking
Slim
uh we've got another game which we
haven't spoken much about which is so
against napomnacy we haven't looked at
that for a while looks as though it's a
pawn up here from Wesley so so he's free
rolling but his King is very very open
I mean probably you're gonna agree with
this with Miss yeah with this Lawrence
is that normally these games are drawn
but there's also such thing which Angels
don't understand it's the Practical part
right and in in Praxis I think these end
games are very very difficult to hold
because you just miss the queen trade
from the blacks perspective and that's
it white is going to win the pawn end
game
uh they're very notorious I mean the
queen end games right one of the
craziest in-games I recall Lawrence is
this uh I think it was with the H Pawn
and the g Pawn Queen's each and the
engines announced it's a draw yet in uh
in the practice of course the stronger
side most of the time wins right because
it's yes so it's so difficult to show
where exactly is this is wrong yes no I
know I know exactly what you mean that
ending
um
yeah and it's a different world when
humans play compared to computers it's
one of the hardest end games to really
master
um John Nunn did some work on it
uh you know to actually publish some
theory on it uh some theory is known but
it's such a difficult endgame to to
master
um that I think a lot of players even
strong Grand Masters have have big
problems so talking about this position
you know Lawrence I'm trying to figure
out how white wants to win this game
most likely his big idea is try to get
the king towards the queen side and
that's why Queen D2 check is played I
mean nepo obviously is dreaming to trade
a couple of Pawns the B Pawn for the C
Pawn everything at the king side while
white is looking for the possibility to
trade queens and that's why G4 was
played trading a couple of Pawns
preparing King F4 King G5 one slip and
black is losing this
yes still work for the Publishers do
we'll come back there because it looks
as though
Carlson is on the verge and indeed
uh it is over Magnus Carlson defeats
Matthias bluebellum with the black
pieces
a very very nice Victory by Magnus that
lovely Pawn sacrifice to generate that
peace activity worked brilliantly after
also has won that position so
it is only Wesley so against the
Promenade she as the remaining game
but um
King is a bit exposed here no there's a
lot of checks from the side is this a
Perpetual check you know I'm thinking
maybe Wesley's likely rushed with the
idea to play G4 the idea I think was
right but it seems that Nippon nashik
has found the right way to give the
checks because this is this is how you
try to make a draw from the weaker's
side you try to uh at least according to
the rules of jazz make 50 moves where
none of the pawns are moving there's no
captures then you call the Arbiter
there's no progress so here essentially
what uh the world championship
Challenger is doing he is trying to give
Perpetual check right and I think that
white is going to have a hard time to
bring the queen to God from the checks
because then they put on B4 might become
vulnerable
yeah White's King is just a little too
open here it looks as though looks as
though Jan is Gonna Save uh sorry uh yes
it looks as though Jan is Gonna Save the
position Jan is with the black pieces uh
so yarn is going to save this position I
believe I think it's very difficult to
avoid these checks Queen F4 played but
there's going to be Queen B3 now and
we're going to get a repetition of of
moves and now the the king really has
got no squares because he can't go to
the fourth rank so you can just even
King E2 you can check on B2
oh C2 is a queen C2 Queen D2 Queen E4 is
of course the way to
to check here
um Wesley so is going to do it it just
amazes me Lawrence howkey does it I mean
it seems such a difficult thing game and
yarn shows it flawlessly he knows what
he's doing he has almost 11 minutes on
the clock and it's like I don't need
this time
well you know Magnus Carlsen said that
he believed Jana publisher was the best
player in the world with heavy pieces so
with queens and Rooks uh Magnus said
nobody in the world plays like Jan uh
and I believe that I remember seeing a
few games of
of Yarns where he just um has finds
maximum output for these pieces
resourcefulness everything you want and
this game is is going to end
reasonably soon it's going to be a bunch
more checks
you can never block the check
successfully as you said artists it's
just
um the pawns are hanging and
Wesley's face there also just says okay
I'm kind of ready
kind of ready Queenie Queenie for check
already
when's upon or what is this
Queen E4 King G3 are so he wants to
sacrifice
uh the the B4 Pawn in order to then land
on F7 but yeah very clever stuff by Jan
he's just not even taking the pawn he's
just giving the continual checks Queen
F4 Queen E1 will now be played
and yeah you just can't can't escape
these checks it's just right that's what
it looks like and of course the body
language of West also says he knows he
is uh he is his chance if he had it Noki
tries the last chance look at this
Lawrence he sacrifice the pawn on B4 uh
with the idea to play Queen of seven
check with some tactical ideas but Yan
doesn't fall into this and uh
he just keeps giving checks yeah exactly
he just doesn't need the pawn he can
just give the checks King G2 Queen E4 is
probably already
uh threefold King H3 Queen D3
and then
Lawrence we have an update on another
result of this door of managed to win
his game against ratterson who had a
great start in the opening phase I loved
his position but then I have a feeling
the greater son and not not greater so
but simply switched to a different gear
different speed and just outplayed his
opponent in the end game and this means
that the world rapid Champion is so far
winning all the matches of course Still
Still this match is still to go but I
mean it's just absolutely stunning
performance so far
what can you say he uh he's incredibly
strong he's Young and Hungry and
all of all of those words that you use
to describe a potential Champion uh for
I mean he's already well rapper champion
he's got a great chance to win this
imagine being a double world champion
artist at the age of 18 World rapid
World Fisher random and let's face it
the Olympiad which is the world team
champions he's already writing his name
in the history books and he's not even
really the finished product yet he's got
plenty of improving left
mm-hmm right but uh I'm looking at this
position Lawrence and I can't help but
feel that Wesley has managed to find
some progress I mean he did put the
queen on C3 so there's no Perpetual
check anymore
and the maybe Wesley is once again ready
to try the Journey of the king towards
the queen side because his only chance
his only chance to win the game is I
mean of course he would love to trade
the queen so it's not going to happen
but get the king towards the queen side
and that's why of course Department she
plays Queen E4 but there's no more
Perpetual check and the bar says listen
I mean this is not so obvious anymore
what about something like H5 can I do
this
yeah fair play to Wesley who is who has
managed to
uh
uh to to somehow find a configuration
which doesn't lead to an immediate
Perpetual check I still feel as though
the position and he's finally played the
move G5 as well
I still feel as though this position has
to be a draw because
Black's Queen on e4 does a tremendous
job of just protecting G6 and C6 so even
if you just move the king here let's say
King to G8 I don't see how white makes
progress if you play Queen F3 I can once
again give the checks I can probably
take on B4 happily as well there and
after Queen takes C6 you should never be
winning this position as wide right two
versus one
yeah you're you're absolutely right but
to be honest I slightly don't like this
G5 uh maybe there was nothing else I was
looking at Queen F3
okay the bar set screen F3 is not a mole
but my idea was to revisit whatever
Wesley was planning before once again
I'm hitting the pawn on C6 after Queen
B4 I wanted to give a check King H6 is
going to be a main threat and after King
AJ probably this is some sort of
Perpetual check but yes also Queenie one
I can also take on H4 at any moment
right Queen E1 oh right the queen E1
yeah that's very clean right right yeah
probably I mean I'm sure that Wesley saw
this so that's why he played G5 and now
he's running towards the queens and look
at the bar
wow what John says
what has happened the bar just went
completely insane
Queen E5 he's allowed the king to cross
over to the queen side and now the
problem you've got is the end of she is
a lot of checks can be blocked
by the queen with and sometimes there's
even a check so after Queen E6 King D3
for example then Queen B3 you go King D4
the king comes to C5 goodness has has
Jan
has Jan actually made a huge blunder
here yeah it definitely looks like a
blunder because I think it was pretty
obvious you don't want to allow the
white king to get towards the queens and
he's doing exactly that this is the only
chance that white ever cast The Pawn on
H4 doesn't really matter I think Wesley
cat forgot about his Pawn at all he
needs to get the king towards the queens
that he needs to get the Kings toward
the pawn on C6 which gives him some
chances and that's why I just don't
understand the Lawrence why do you play
Queen E5 Queen E5 just in white white
king to be pushed towards the queen side
I think he's just hallucinate to
something
quite astonishing
and Jan
wow if he loses this he will be sick
he will be absolutely sick to lose this
position because it's just not a
position you should be losing under any
circumstances
uh
uh total
yeah no I mean
sniper but against Wesley I think it's
just I was telling this from the black
practical perspective right it's just
yes okay it's a draw I mean there's
supposed to be a draw and then comes the
actual practice the Practical game the
nerves hallucinations
Etc because white is not risking
anything and and he's just pushing and
pushing and pushing he's like asking you
uh are you sure this is a draw so you
find it first time the second time for
the fifth time for the tenth time but
for the 20th time you make a mistake
incredible
and now this King sitting on C3
doing a great job now because you can
put you can you can protect it from the
checks you can do everything uh the king
can be an active piece an attacking
piece
I mean this is this is a disaster for
Nepal machine you can see in his body
language as well
he hasn't got the best poker face in the
on the planet that's for sure
um so this is
I mean
if Wesley wins this this isn't just
winning one point this is like a this is
a two-point full swing because you're
not supposed to win this so um
but Jana's Jana's made this mistake
before kazaki right I mean he's very
very fast and sometimes he just uh does
it a bit too quick and Magnus also
pointed it out so I think uh was it
prior after the world championship but
sometimes this happens to Jan right he
just he's a very fast player brilliant
player one of the best players in the
world and sometimes he does it I mean he
just plays a bit too fast in those
critical positions
something happens like we just witnessed
it and there you go I mean this is not a
draw anymore I'm not even sure if this
is salvageable because I don't see an
easy way how the black how black is
going to stop the Vikings March towards
the queen side
I agree and this King can use the C Pawn
as a shield it can go to C5 and then B6
and it can dance around that c Pawn a
lot of the time and you're right I don't
see how you save this now I just don't
see how you save this yeah so King C5
cannot be allowed I think this is
immediately uh if black loses the spawn
I mean
with such an exposed game with so many
checks where the pawn guarding the king
Sheltering the king from checks the
queen as well the pawn H4 doesn't matter
at all don't you even think about it uh
I don't know sort of like Queen G1
probably he has to be played what is
gonna most likely centralize the queen
something like Queen D3 Queenie for
something and the king is pretty sure
gonna make it to C6
yeah absolute catastrophe here for
uh for uh yeah napometershy in game one
wow just
I tell you if you would have told me
artists
you know when the King was on H3 and it
was getting checked
I would have if you would have said to
me
you can have a lot of money on this
position being a draw
I would have sent you a lot of money to
make that bet but because it just seems
so unlikely that Wesley's King was going
to get out
but now we have this incredible position
where I did you know it didn't seem like
a fourth draw right it did seem like
there was just no way Hawaii is going to
make a progress then Wesley made his uh
I what I felt was Improvement King on H3
the queen on C3 now there was no
Perpetual check and just some kind of uh
brain lag mostly for uh nipomishi
allowing the king to get to the queens
and now
I'll just say this is lost yeah and I
think it is of course yeah it's just
lost because the king is going to March
towards uh the pawn on C6
um Queen C4 check is immediate threat
that uh black needs to be worried about
Queen G6 is also a threat King G7 is
Queen C3 King H7 uh most likely H5
that's it you just resigned here no I
mean how do I think here I think resigns
is not premature here G6 is too weak as
you said Queen C4 is a threat it's just
it's just a catastrophe and I do believe
we will I mean Jan is not one to resign
early that's actually true yayan is is
not the type to resign early
um however
I have no doubt that Wesley's going to
convert this position it's just there
are just too many routes
um even here King H7 H5
is that weird because Queen G5 Queen G's
I he went Queen Jesus did H5 win I mean
that's a sort of stupid move I would
play and lose but actually King G6 King
C4 king of 65. oh look at this
you is the ball of the check I mean this
is an amazing technique right so Queen
E7 queen of six queen of seven you
always you always win the bond of the
check King gate shade Queen effect King
H7 Queen H6 Jackie win the pawn with a
check
ah yes great technique
yeah so he just collects the pawn on G6
with a check and uh now of course Jan is
gonna play for a while you can always
resign nobody has made points by
resigning early but
you can only blame himself
yeah he's gonna be extremely angry uh If
he if he does lose this because
he of course knows that this was okay
and now we see the shaking of the head
yeah yeah this is just the the king is
protected here I I now I actually expect
resignation by Jan because the two pawns
really are too much nope he carries on
okay
let's see
H5 to connect Parts pawns no checks
Queen G5 tried
and
well
a miracle is required here foreign
trying to set up the position here so
this is the actual position yes um queen
of three
Queen F3 any I mean any move is good
what about H6 do you like that one you
played Queen F2
uh H6 with the idea of uh Queen takes H6
Queen G3 check and G7
also looked particularly strong but
everything is good
uh
now so
yeah Queen F2 Queens no Queen C5 is
obviously very good as well so Queen F2
King A6 Queen C5 is on the board as well
right
Queen G2
okay just need I guess you can get four
oh Queen G2 obviously
it is one way to uh to not do what you
want this reminds me this reminds me
Lauren some Notorious checkmates having
up two points in the queens and again
missing checkmates it's of course
possible the cast happened before so
white needs to be careful
I like Queen C4 because you cover the A2
Square yeah I like it
okay King right seven I guess
and Wesley now playing with his left
hand do you notice he switches he plays
with his right during most of the game
and then he plays with his left yeah now
he's just gonna go G7 and so what does
it mean I mean he want to keep playing
with the left hands like uh showing
super confidence I'm gonna do this right
yeah exactly
super confidence
Queen B3 checks out the Jeep on is one
step away from being promoted so white
needs to make sure there's no more
tricks I guess King A4 Queen okay Queen
C3 Queen D1 check game three
unfortunately for black there's no
checks again notice how Wesley's done
that twice the King on A3 Queen on C3
King on B3 Queen on D3 it it's a very
cute way just to cover the checking
squares from behind I like it very much
and uh Wesley this is this is gonna be
resigns I think now now if he resigns
yeah
that's a that's a this is where you
resign yeah this is this is now your
resign as Mr schabel would say right
yeah exactly now this is resigns for
sure
um okay he's C5 okay one last throw of
the dice
C5 what is that move what am I looking
he wants to activate the king I guess
this Pawn doesn't matter I mean you're
losing anyway beta X King C6 the king's
exposed some minor chances
but uh
you could just go H6 of course yeah this
is this is of course the the classic
lovely just ignoring the pawn yeah they
get I guess Queen B4 check something
like King C8 could be played a king seat
is Queen of Fate King C7
uh the screen on F7 is not on the spot
to deliver a lot of checks to the King
on Adrian actually I'm not even sure
that white could save it if the white
king makes the h8 so
it's just a matter of time
I played King Size before curious
yeah this is good enough
this is easily good enough
I think he's just simply going to run
towards the king side that's it I mean
yeah just just goes to King G4 King G5
tries King on h8 H7
these bonds are definitely going to
promote I think he realized this is the
easiest technique and I think also Jan
recognizes it
but you always have to fight it out like
uh right Lawrence because of course sure
you never know maybe there is a mouse
lip some brain like something happens
oh well there's still a chance to save
the game
so Queen Bee Tree
crazier things that's the last move yeah
that's the last move now there's going
to be discovered check and the G8 Queen
yeah that that is actually going to be
the last move
because you you Queen would check and uh
uh two queens is gonna be a little bit
too much even up for the great yarn I
don't see an Abomination making them all
here no I think it's I think Wesley I
was already expecting it yeah
yeah
in these moments they recollect what
happened the game sometimes before you
stop the clock you try to figure out
what happened
no no he's surprising me yeah and I have
no idea why he's carrying on but
it is his prerogative he can continue to
King C3 check King A4 check whatever
it's just
it's just winning Queen B4 yeah
that is enough for today's first game
little discussion between these two
a bloody first round oh to us let's have
a look at the results very quickly
right so treat the size of results out
of four just one draw to be honest it's
not
not not really surprising uh the only
draw was uh in the game of Hikaru again
stuff at the Sev here you see the score
sheets uh uh of the sator of as we
already predicted prior the match
Lawrence is a favorite uh in the match
against gretelson so he won his game a
nice style Magnus Carlsen shows why he's
the world champion
and Wesley so shows why he's the
reigning world just 960 world champion
indeed and we're going to go now for a
very short break uh uh and uh yes but
first before we go there of course this
is chess.com's coverage of the fish at
random uh chess championships presented
by Brave and if you want to know a
little bit more about Brave well Brave
is
uh
uh private browsing if you're interested
in being secure online it means private
browsing and so much more by default
Brave blocks ads and trackers on every
page uh and uh of course
uh even on YouTube
uh there are no ads and it means that
you have three times faster page loads
faster streaming faster playback it
means 35 longer battery life or mobile
data Internet bandwidth and so on
available for Android iOS and desktop
get yourselves acquainted with brave
we'll be right back though with more
coverage of the Fisher random World
Championship
Rave see you soon run for my life
okay
what's up man hey just solving some
puzzles
get my coffee
oh shoot
which one is that is that our new one
yeah
I can't get this one man
what's wrong with you man
um
this is hard
you sure you're feeling okay
uh one got it oh shoot
oh
the only thing better than chess is more
chess so don't miss a moment of the
Fisher random world championship before
the women's candidates we will be Squad
streaming
foreign
[Music]
this is the test.com broadcast of the
Fisher random chess championships
brought to you by Brave and we can see
there a shot of the playing Hall while
we wait for game number two of day two
uh artists we've just seen
a a very very interesting uh
first game a lot of blood on the board
any thoughts from
from that first uh round let's call it
of today
right so three
so we have uh at the moment six minutes
until the matches so so there's a little
break still still some time to go so
throwing back what happened
uh I was I was really uh impressed at
least by the opening part
um it was difficult as usual which is
quite common for just 96 to figure out
what's happening in openings
I loved absolutely that in the game of
uh Wesley so against Diana ponachi both
players made the so-called long Castle
shortcast long Castle but then again
did anybody else make it
I don't recall
all right so yes Wesley Wesley and uh
there was I think one more player did as
well but yes it was it was cute to see
the as you call it the short long
castling or what was the words you use
some something to that effect short long
Castle long short guys whatever you call
it very very nice yes
very very nice indeed and a lot of
inspirational play and uh again I have
to give a proper
um shout out so to speak to greterson
because despite the fact that he is uh
an underdog in this event it's it's very
very difficult for him to face the best
place in the world uh I I loved what he
was doing in the game against stop the
satorov but probably something happened
when Abdul sotorov tried to launch this
queen side assault with A5 A4 and he
just didn't properly evaluate his
position and probably Lawrence you're
gonna agree with me on this is that at
this level I mean the best place in the
world grammasters professional chess
players they pretty much rarely they
make blunders but the problem is usually
the evaluation so let's say from afar
you see something you think it's great
right and then you place it like five
six moves and then you just realize it's
not great just pretty bad
yeah I mean uh that that tends to happen
a lot as well of course
um and yeah we've got a we've got an
interesting
uh an interesting moment now in this uh
in this round because there are a lot of
players who also need to actually win uh
to stay alive so with three different
size results Matthias blue band one of
them had a horrible game against Magnus
got completely outclassed of course he's
a great player he's uh are you qualified
through the the open qualifiers and uh
he's uh
uh you know on his day a very very
competent capable player but uh it's
you're living in Magnus world now and
it's uh it's no fun when uh Magnus is
concentrated and he's determined and
Magnus values this title very highly
this is not a just a random tournament
for Magnus
so uh Matthias absolutely must win of
course if Matthias doesn't win and
Magnus wins this mini match they play
another mini match so this is game two
or four today so we've got a lot more
chairs to go
which is of course wonderful for all of
us and do uh give us your ideas in chat
uh we've got our tours uh he's uh he's
watching everything very very uh closely
uh so if you've got some good feedback
please do and uh
would be glad to
to hear from you and thank you for
supporting the stream of course by being
here
it's great uh from facility and actually
you know Lawrence there's one thing I
wanted to mention is that I I see that
qualification path for FedEx and the
blue bomb they beat a lot of strong
armisters in the qualifications but do
you know that also I was taking the part
of the qualification
oh you took part did you I didn't know
yeah no yeah sure I was I was trying to
qualify my this was pretty much my only
experience in just 960. I had never
played it before I played in one of the
online qualifiers and well let's just
say I got tilted
so it was very tough um the field was
very very
um impressive and there was a lot of
exciting games but still I definitely I
definitely enjoyed it and I see that of
course that fedes AF and um
bluebound made it
yes they did I didn't participate
I uh I just uh I
chest 960. it's a different world to me
still somehow so uh yeah I don't know uh
it's uh yeah it's one of those ones uh
but uh I I'm curious by it I I am
interested in in the variant I think
it's a very very interesting game and
well
I'm curious how this tournament right
right brings up I mean just 960 is
definitely developing and uh it's
amazing to see uh that uh it's finding
its place in the Chess World right I
mean I still remember when was this
Lawrence you're probably gonna correct
me it was something like in early 2000s
there was this one unofficial world
championship tournament in Mainz Germany
right yes I used to play it and then
they stopped then they stopped it there
was like a quiet uh period of uh several
years and I'm very happy they rebooted
it and I think this the chess 960 and
various uh ongoing transparents they
just they just add some richness to the
game of chess and I think they're gonna
find a a way to coexist together with
with the classical chess which I still
believe is not that there's so many ways
to explore it but of course just 96 is
just different different Beast
yeah it really is
um
they will co-exist I don't think 960
will ever take over traditional chess
but I think there's certainly room for
it to grow and with the endorsement of
the world champion Hikaru Nakamura uh
the likes of Jana pondicherry of course
could be world champion let's remember
folks that janapamnashi will be facing
ding for the world championship title as
Magnus steps aside
um a lot of these endorsements mean a
lot so it's it's certainly a an
interesting time
for 960. as the second game of this
mini-match gets underway so
yeah well it has been played yeah
one of my favorite moves it's not the
birds opening because it's not a it's
not a uh starting position but uh
F4 by Magnus Carlson I think actually I
look at this he blunted he blundered the
pawn on move one look at this F4 D5 uh
you can't take on A7 because of Knight
B6 this is very curious artists I think
we have to show this
so Magnus always goes for the cheap
tricks right he plays F4 and also the
first game he played C6 with a black
collar going after the power NATO and
here he opens with F4 Queen A7 I guess
Knight B6 and after Rook A8 black
instant activates his Rook so this is
actually not a blunder it's a trick
it's a
traps Laura it's like you have to go
back um to be honest I'm disappointed in
Magnus that he wants to play G4 you know
I mean he was he started the game
yesterday against he carved with G5 I
think actually G4 here is pretty normal
yeah like you you gain space you
activate the queen and you want to play
F4 so F4 is just a bit too normal to me
hey
well and look at this F4 D5 D4 optically
looks ugly as you like giving up this E4
square but there's no Knight that can
get there there's no Bishop that can get
there so Magnus uh you know it just
doesn't jump to E4 it's impossible no it
just doesn't get there not not quickly
anyway
so f45 D4 E6 okay well
also makes a lot of sense
I'm trying to figure out what is this
probably
some sort of a night move Knight H
Knight G3 or Knight F2 I I would say
Knight G3 makes sense to play E4 next
because I think this sort of resembles
the Marazzi by let's say if I manage to
play E4 at some point D dakes and 94
recapture to spawn on these pawns like
horns there limiting blacks
potentially do something active when he
plays and now he plays G4 but this is
not the moment when you should play G4
wow
very very interesting stuff this looks a
bit random to me this looks like Magnus
having a bit of fun I mean I don't know
I don't know if I'm a fan he's trying to
gain space he's saying okay the the
black Queen's still on G8 the Black
Knight is still on h8 the black Bishop
isn't doing much so I'll just gain some
space
very interesting my goodness we have to
go to the napometry so game because what
on Earth is going on there can somebody
explain to me what this position is
oh
um
I assume we don't go the opening phase
right I mean probably it's not it's not
really necessary but it's very obvious
that Wesley like uh in the previous game
uh blue bomb doesn't care about opponent
A7 it's the same track right Queen A7
Knight B6 again the Knight jumps out
through K8 try to capture the Queen the
bishop on C4 on bonuses uh also
disconnected but look at the queen on G8
um I wasn't gonna join the game that's
why Bishop C4 was played by nepomishi
because neponish also has doubts that
this queen is gonna find the game that
awaits the game so easily
yes yes a valid a valid point I guess
Knight B6 is coming though very quickly
hitting this bishop right so that's kind
of an important Point uh that's why he
plays A3 to bring the bishop back to A2
this is this is very very interesting
stuff so he wants to keep the bishop on
this diagonal but if he would for
example here played Bishop B3 this would
accomplish the same thing but the Nathan
A1 has certain objections right and
that's why that's why he plays A3 so
that he can play Bishop A2 and after
Knight B3
maybe there's a way to activate the
Knight
well I think also it's difficult though
yeah I I think that I think a lot of
these guys are having fun uh playing
this uh these nights in the corner make
quite the impression don't they all the
nights in the corner uh to start it's an
interesting starting position of course
I imagine there are lots of starting
positions where there are two nights in
the corner
because there are 960 positions right so
uh God's not in them all you can't study
them all precisely
and Bishop C6 makes sense right you want
to play Bishop D5 kill this bishop so
that the black queen on G8 can find a
way to join the game maybe even Bishop
D5 Trader Bishop Supply F5 get the
center and get the queen out
I like it I like it for black if you get
Bishop D5 Knight B6 F5 all this energy
in your position this looks
this looks just really good no
yeah I like it I like it as well so I
think that neponishi didn't get much if
there's even such a thing
uh in the just 960 opening Theory
all right what do we do do we mean let's
check another yeah let's move on let's
check another game I have to say fit
save against Nakamura the the first game
was just a snooze Fest it was it was
just dead drawed from very early on but
this one has got potential let's go to
to nakamura's game
[Music]
and uh just before fear played Knight C3
I wanted to add there's a potential to
blunder something for example you play
let's say Knight C5 which is a very
normal looking move slowly boom which
page five are you losing the change just
like that
you can only get this in just 960 right
unbelievable
right so yeah
no Knight C3 keeps an idea to play
bishopy to protecting the E2 Square just
in case black is thinking about which
page five ideas
right
all right
okay well yeah there's million ways to
continue right there's G5
activating the queen activating the
bishop
and it's played look at that look at
this this is this is Hikaru in uh
you know Hikaru Hikaru and Hikaru moved
F6 G5 Bishop H5 he's saying give it to
me I you know I I'm ready to play an
active game and I I kind of
optically I like what black is doing but
the bar is saying something completely
different so I clearly know nothing
about Chess but this looks
good for black and I don't understand
why it's good for Wyatt maybe the bar
says that this is better for white
because black has slightly worse Pawn
structure right because what he has not
done anything wrong I mean okay the
Knight on Knight on B3 C3 they are
taking care of a lot of squares around
them right I guess they should be good
pieces white can always play bishopito
while black will have to prove what
exactly he has for perhaps slightly
ruined Pawn structure out of King side
maybe that's why that's why the bar says
it's slightly better but to be honest I
I wouldn't like come into this position
and announce that white is so much
better
yes
an interesting one nonetheless
um
green G5 strange yeah Bishop B2 Queen G5
and he took first also 92 Queen G5 again
don't understand the bar has actually
come down quite a bit now so
should we have a look at Abdul saturov
perhaps as well we should probably look
at his game this is pretty normal okay
um
this looks sort of familiar to one of
the previous games I can't recall which
one
yeah a little bit more classical it
feels doesn't it with the with the
center as it is
so what is taken the center black is
trying to counter it and try to find
some weak spots in White's position like
Knight F4 maybe H5 H4
foreign
yeah and again and again the problems
right Lawrence we discussed it in the in
the previous games that what he has this
shows with a cast link and this is
something he probably can't
uh find an answer to immediately I guess
you normally what you want to do you
want to fight for the center you want to
bring out your most awkward pieces and I
think in this uh Choice with the Knights
on A1 a knight on H1 it makes perfect
sense first to activate those Knights
try to try to get the center and then
see whatever happens
yeah
totally agree okay let's leave this one
because it's a little bit quiet let's go
back to
where maybe we should stay with feather
save because I mean that's a lot of
action we spent almost no time on it
um right we almost missed the entire
previous games right we quickly checked
it and then they had a very quiet
position and somehow the final draw
Bishop g39 G6 so this is a fight for the
central squares essentially so FedEx
wants to block them and Nakamura on the
opposite wants to not allow them to be
blocked so that's why 96 Bishop G7 E5 is
something that he probably is thinking
about
mm-hmm
yeah it's
interesting 94.
yeah I guess that 99. look at this weird
looking move Knight 90 to D4
again the bar is just straight down the
middle here the bar is what about this
one I mean obviously there's a fork
threat but what how do you stop for
example
Knight B5 ah you just want to jump like
this huh
how do you stop it
yeah it's
it's
weirdly awkward
how it's equal even I don't understand
it because I see two very difficult to
Parry threats I mean for example the bar
says this is nothing for whatever reason
like
I don't know E5 not A7 King B7 Arc and
nobody plays like this
you're right nobody does play like this
very very strange
I don't understand this position at all
you know and I think that's the problem
sometimes with with 960
or or Fisher random of course we're
we're using these terms interchangeably
is there are just some Concepts that
even though they are chess concepts are
just for me this is so alien to to play
like this you know to play E5 night
before allow what I mean these are moves
that I don't even
you know uh
I I don't take no it's not that I don't
take seriously but they're difficult for
me to conceptualize but I will say one
thing Vladimir save
who's an extremely strong Grandmaster
I have commentated a lot of events in my
life okay and I can tell you this
he is one of the Players whose moves I
never guess I can't guess any of his
moves I don't understand how he plays
chess I've got absolutely no idea what
he's doing
um
it's it he's he's a player who's a
complete Enigma to me so it doesn't
surprise me at all actually that these
sorts of positions are coming up and I
think Hikaru though has got quite a good
record against him if I understand
correctly speaking about Hikaru I also
wanted to add that also Hikaru in my
eyes he's one of those players who is
incredibly difficult to predict right
yes at least I I used to play against
many many games online and I I still
remember the thought process right I
mean right here at just.com obviously
and uh when you're calculating like a
normal human being the first move the
second mode the third ball he just fires
out the fifth move you're just not
looking at that he's just thinking
completely differently yes and it's just
very very difficult to adjust to it and
I have a theory that he simply has
trained to think differently right maybe
specifically for online chess and uh
he's such an amazing credit player but
uh just for for the average grammasters
for standard grammasters though adjust
to it it's incredibly difficult
yeah totally agree and a lot of these
top players the creative guys the guys
have got good spatial awareness as well
that's another thing that I find with
960 they really Excel out it it does
show the difference in class
interpretation uh of positions it shows
you know
all kinds of you know how they see the
interaction of pieces it's
it's very interesting stuff very very
interesting
I love this move 94 I mean it's a very
creative move it comes with direct
threats 96 Knight B5 I think actually
Hikaru is more concerned about Knight B5
so I would think that he is in a very
deep think either he barries the Knight
E6 threat or he's calculating some even
deeper stuff I mean there is a room for
that I I could even mention something as
crazy as F4 and you try to be super
creative with 96 queen of five 98 x
takes on G3 and what the north is this
right so the Knight on d8 is trapped
there's definitely room for
improvisation here
no absolutely
should we move to another let's go back
to to magnus's game
let's do it
so
so what is this I mean white space
Advantage is considerable and um
I think that uh one of the one of the
things that sometimes at the club level
I I think we probably have to explain a
bit why space Advantage is so important
it just allows you to do a lot of good
things behind you meaning you push
forward those pawns and then you have
more space more Loft to do something
good and when you look at the position
uh I think that for
while it's a bit easier to do things
because
when I try to understand what black is
supposed to do probably
not C5 because this weekend's the king
probably not the E5 and maybe something
like f6e5
so why does a bit enjoying the space
Advantage I have a feeling maybe there's
even something like I'm thinking
something like H4 H4 Knight H4 uh Queen
H1 push away this Knight Queen H7
and
I'm not going to be very original
I like white
yeah totally agree I think this is one
of those positions which you know that
space Advantage as you said is is going
to be
really really important for uh
for Magnus and I think he's going to be
very happy with this position I mean in
general I think you have to be happier
with such a position
yeah he has every reason to be happy yes
every single reason to be happy no
fireworks just here yet though
right
but there's definitely definitely ways
to improvise I'm even looking at some
crazy ideas like Knight C5 you know
probably totally unnecessary Knight C5
sacrifice the pawn then limit this
Knight with B3 Bishop C3 activating this
bishop but Magnus instead played
something more
classical what did they play by the way
I don't see it I don't see it either
let's see no no nothing has really
happened but let's go to Federal save
Nakamura because we've got absolute
action over there
uh incredible action over there so let's
go have a look at that so after Knight
D4
what happened Nakamura this sacrifice
this Pawn look at that yes he he did
sacrifice the pawn indeed
um
and now we've got just an incredibly
sort of random position here
the bar loves white though a random
position in official random chance I
like that
yes so now today's seven is clearly
struggling uh to find a way back in the
game and this was clearly hikaru's idea
uh to sacrifice it that's why he played
F4 so that the White Knight cannot
easily find a way back and also somehow
combined with rookie8 and some space
advantage in the center this is what
Hikaru wants but it just brings the
question what if I play something like
some human move like A4
and I want to play an ib5 next and I try
to imprison your knight with C6 is it
ever gonna get out
it might not but then again you might
not be able to Win It
so can I just say okay so what
then again what am I supposed to do here
with white because my pieces
they look a bit strange
you know very looking at this I'm not
even sure what is Black's threat because
the snap is like double protected here
yeah it's it's very very it's very
strange
it's very very strange and imagine on
top of that you are the top gramister
you can try to give this a fair
evaluation I you know I have a feeling
that most of the time they're just
guessing really I mean this is just
impossible impossible to properly valid
as you look at this position and I think
the only thing which comes to your mind
is okay this is fun this is crazy let's
try this right there's just nothing as
you're controlling whatever happened
here but I mean look at this last move
rookie four I mean this is such a better
safe move I mean
uh this move is so alien I yeah he wants
to go Rook A4 and Knight C6 check out
the guy's the biggest genius in the
world basically I mean it's just that
simple
I mean this is just brilliant I mean I
love this move
what a brilliant move
so I think they're pretty much so far in
in this mini round the most creative
players who are not uh striving for the
normalcy because Lawrence uh I mean we
discussed this uh in the first game
today when the most additional response
usually is that you try to get a normal
position as quickly as possible so that
you can apply your knowledge you can
apply your patterns
but here this is just insane right
yeah this is this is this is
I mean this is a
have you ever seen a chess position like
this in your life and the answer it has
to be no right this is just
I mean the only thing I can think of
Lawrence here is you have to respond
with something adequate which is very
close to rookie force uh quality maybe
something like kinky Saturn yeah that
would be really nice just to play King
Easter I mean if it's the best move I I
you know I give up but uh it feels that
is the best one
but the bar doesn't hate it really I
mean it's a playable move oh my goodness
goodness me I mean he's not playing King
E7 right I mean it's just two
even for hikara this is just too much
surely
I don't know okay maybe he wants to play
Bishop D6 and then King E7 maybe that
makes sense but then again when you have
a very deep thought that the
better say it actually is going to be
activated the King on E7 is weird but I
don't care if it's weird if it works it
works right you get a king towards the
king's side and has this guy castled by
the way
uh he can't Castle anymore oh no he
can't Castle because he's moved his King
already so you play King his son yeah
maybe you're right but it you're not
worried about some
well if the bar doesn't hate it then
it's probably not losing right that's
the point I'll just play I'll just play
it for the style points really you know
uh you can play rookie for I can play
King E7 let's have a good laugh together
you know but but again on a serious note
I mean what do you do with this um we'll
decide on A7
yeah I agree it's I don't know
it's a weird one it's it's very very odd
it's it's all very very weird
to say the least really really weird
yeah all right what do we do do we look
at this weirdness or we I think we look
at it I think we look at another I think
we look at another game actually let's
have a look at the
uh nepomishi Wesley so remember she
needs to win in order to
stay uh sort of in contention for this
particular mini match
what's going on here
what on Earth is going on here is the
question I'm pretty sure that black is
going to sacrifice the pot on B6 I mean
the the point is let's say I'm gonna
make some random or let's say G6 which
is completely ridiculous move and maybe
this is what Wesley would be thinking
about because now the bottom B6 actually
shelters the king but then you think
about how janapamnashi is thinking he's
not going to care about opponent B6 no
he's gonna play A6 to explore the kid
um
I like this this is very nice indeed
very very nice indeed yeah
except for the bar of course except for
the I mean everywhere we like that then
the ball goes crazy I mean well so what
happened so uh it looks as though there
was a move
uh you should there was a move uh five
Bishop B4
yeah and this is what happens right they
take some B6 and A6 except off my
prediction skills when slightly wrong
there was no A6
right
but then Asics and at least now for the
moment Hikaru has you know managed to
uh sorry Wesley I beg your pardon Wesley
has managed to stop the the action down
there you know just a second Lawrence
can I take it there's a fork
wait what there's Queen C5 check oh
there's going to oh my goodness you just
ruined that I I thought there's gonna be
a queen sacrifice of some sort something
like bdx and A7 90 to check King B1
promote another queen and then we play a
normal chess but okay Queen C
you're right you're right
you're right yeah unfortunately just
Queen yeah and that that wins so that's
that's good
um Rook A4 look at these Rooks today
they're all on the fourth rank we're
okay four
wow okay makes sense
it definitely does I mean it's a bit odd
move but uh uh after Rook A4 what
activates the rook and A1 Bishop C3 B
takes on C3 all right
I really like wise possession you know
why because I have a feeling that what
he has excellent chances uh to conduct
some sort of a queen side attack at
least I mean in Ideal World right I'm
gonna play C4 C5 remove the queen Nana
F5 and C6 if that happens black is
busted
but the bar is loving black so some is
there a tactic here that we're just not
seeing or what's going on here there
could be some sort of a 92 Rook C8
Knight C3 ideas on The Rook on D1
perhaps is unprotected enough I mean I
don't know
can we do this Rooks oh you want to go
Knight E2 first okay I'm not really sure
to be honest
and then I want to play Knight C3
okay
oh well wait actually it's a fork now I
know it is yeah it's just it just wins
yeah there's another Fork
unbelievable oh my goodness Okay so it's
actually a pretty legit idea no so beta
X 90 to check
can be to Rook C8
how do you stop wow you don't
I don't know but the bar says it's equal
how it's equal
I have no idea
I don't understand at all there's no
Queen G1
to protector Queen
and queen anywhere Knight takes E3 why
why is this equal this is completely
bizarre
maybe there's some
some exchange sacrifice like
I have no idea maybe sacrifice
something like this this just looks what
and the boss says this is win no
what is this what queen
yeah yeah no that doesn't work
so much
I don't get that
do you understand anything oh my God you
understand so this is the first time
I've ever commentated on
Fisher random and it's doubting
my
uh ability to read chess positions in
any at any level whatsoever you're
looking at this it's saying white is
winning and like
it's insane and this is insane Rook
takes A6 Queen E7 Is that real life
let's check this but this is too much
fun nadita Jack can be yet here it makes
sense right
yeah it makes sense it makes perfect
sense so how do you stop
you are cool as a cucumber you play
Knight C3 uh Queen A3 and apparently
this is a big mistake
wow that's
that's completely insane yeah this uh
this queen is completely disconnected
Rooks are disconnected there's no
defense from Queen A7 wow okay but this
wasn't played because there's another
cool move and I did feed check wow
another I mean this is so much fun uh
Queen takes B3 and what's going on here
but this feels a little bit more
but even here I would be worried as
white right
because my king whose King is weaker
whose King is weaker well what has
happened
actually born and this Pawn on H4 also
is under attack
another one that I just can't really
read at all
we've got the word actually Lawrence
that there's been a Blazer in feather
saves game I guess we have to show it
let's have a look let's just call it
unclear
this is this is what is
is this a real position I I it feels as
though this is what's happened okay I
have a nephew he's one years seven it's
gone right
well the 197 is gone I've got a nephew
one year old okay and this is what he's
done he's taken the pieces and he's just
put them randomly on the board that's
what he's done he's just taken the
pieces from the bag and put them this is
the most
crazy it genuinely feels like I I just
haven't really seen something like this
before to be brutally honest it's not
it's very very very crazy this is not a
blunder Laurence I mean definitely and
also the viewers this is intentional
sacrifice I mean there's no way there's
no way that uh faders safe decided uh to
uh drop a piece just like that I think
he just declined repetition I mean Rook
A4 96 Rook A5 Knight C4 maybe this
already was a draw I mean as weird as it
looks it's a draw so that's why he
played Rook B5 he sacrificed the Knight
on A7 so that he can play Bishop C5 now
there's some various tactical motives
like Bishop B6 Bishop okay maybe not
p7 but Bishop B6 the queen hangs
so he cars just plays King Syed which
maybe just maybe was missed by feather
safe because it Dodges any checks and
any Bishop A7 a buffet there's
always Queen B5 and white still is down
a piece
and I need to look at that
wow wow
wow 92.
I'm just I'm just stunned to be honest
you know I can't even thought what what
I'm looking at I honestly feel like I'm
playing a new game looking at this okay
you know what I'm making no
it feels like I'm playing a different
kind of chess
takes he wants to go F3 check or what is
this stuff here what are we looking at
here uh you told me
I don't know I've got no idea okay after
we check
so
there's like
the point is that yeah the King goes to
C3 I think we're happy and if it goes to
E1
can we now do so let me just see here
what we can do uh can we even play
something like
how is this winning this bishop takes E5
Queen takes C5 right so oh wait there's
some
Queen E5 and queen E2 is coming right
maybe this is the entire sequence
wow you've got that intermediate check
oh that's so beautiful
let's see something like that from afar
I mean just uh I've never looked at this
this is alien chest to me yeah no this
is completely alien I mean this is uh
clearly when Hikaru played Knight X on
dito right he sees this yes it's just
insane oh no okay I can understand now
he does Bishop C5 and I guess after Rook
C4 let's let me just put it on board
Bishop C5 Rook C4 there's probably some
very cool move like whatever I don't
know B6 B4 yeah and Hikaru has figured
out whatever 95.
Rook C3 and some sort of a follow-up
which is still some
Rook A3
I mean I'm just having fun now right
yeah that makes two of us
so okay whatever so he has figured out
something here and uh but the craziest
part is here I mean King D2 F3 that you
have to see from afar all of these jumps
like King C3 is still so clear by the
way
it feels bad though right with the King
on C3 it does feel like the king is kind
of in some weird net there but who knows
for sure right and this is winning yeah
yeah
wow
I mean so far it's just so beautiful
this is a this is the move of the round
so far I'll tell you yeah Knight takes
D2 is just stunning stunning more I mean
the dark games like a gem you just want
to print a book the best games of Chess
960 top top 100 games I don't know this
is gonna be one of them definitely
yeah you're watching history here
so F3 is on the board
ah this is and this is exactly the sort
of position you don't want against a
calculator like Hikaru Nakamura right
just uh somebody who calculates as good
as anybody in chess basically especially
in these open board positions this is a
catastrophe
this is not what you want
um right
okay so what happens after King C3
this is really so bad yeah okay so let's
try Bishop G7 check
and I play Bishop before
yeah and now we need to now we need a
really good move
now we need a really good move
something like Knight F4 maybe oh that's
a very nice move wow 92 Knight D5
wow Knight F4 is so pretty
goodness I think for the city is losing
this
no no for sure if he goes King C3 I
think it's just yeah but how do you play
a Queenie treat there's also this one
yeah Queen E3 we saw this this is what
we saw no no no no
can you even see this King you want
Queen E5 uh Queen E3 here sorry right
and it's 58
and now the big point is if I play King
E1
now can I go like Queen can I start
sacking things Queen takes G2 yes Queens
HD2 because Bishop A7 Bishop B4
uh they're they're just losing
apparently oh there's some counter
attack with Queenie sex yeah the black
king is a bit weak ah Queen E6 I
blundered sorry yeah no this is yeah I'm
sorry but it's still somehow winning
okay so King U1 huh
oh wait you just like an E3 what I'm
talking about yeah just like on E3
and then you can grab the Rook on B4 for
free
that's it
uh so black is up a rook yeah this is
just winning right yeah this is just
winning uh I think
um
uh rookie year check uh King you want to
lose this King C3 most likely
loses after King C3 you can play Bishop
G7 and after Bishop E4 you play Queen E3
if you're really creative you can try to
run forward and hope for the best but I
don't think it's
if we see King C4 on the board I will be
just yeah right
yeah I mean if we see if we see this
World I'll be
in shock to say the least I I mean
it will be incredible
okay
no it it can't it can't yeah
but Rook diet is probably gonna follow
us okay Karo is
yeah great shape what about Magnus let's
let's go to Magnus we haven't gone there
for a while let's scoot over of course
it pains me to go go away from this game
but uh yes
we'll just have a quick look at Magnus
shall we yep just a quick little look
so a much more calm Affair at least at
the moment
Magnus is doing Magnus tanks as usual I
mean he has two Bishops he has more
space his King is more safe
yeah he just understands this position a
bit better
um
there's also this idea of playing H4 H5
which I try to make work a bit earlier
actually how do you defend from the
check you know maybe let's start with
this because it's not easy no no I've
been looking at this position trying to
figure out like none of the blocks look
good to me
um like uh
you know they already have played
something else don't they okay oh
there's been a few moves actually
there's been a few moves so just try to
figure out what they were
wait
there was some kind of a breakthrough
was it
wait Bishop
right uh I think there was something
strange some sort of a breakthrough in
the in the center so he managed to
activate the bishop
against space yeah let's
let's come back to that one because that
one I can't I can't really work out but
um Jana punishi is is is Yan doing the
business
let's come back to Magnus because this
position is a little bit too
um
too advanced
uh so all of those
ended up with nothing for Wesley all of
this beautiful uh sequence of 93 Jack
Queen takes on B3 it looked really great
but I think I did already say the
pawners are born right and it looked
really nicely but yeah exactly Jan just
took the pawn right he's like okay so
where is your mate I'm just gonna take
the pawn on H4
and
this is called I got and he just won a
poem I just want a pawn Pawn's a poem my
bad once a point I'm Rook H5 threatens
Rook h8 mate
so you don't have time to collect B6 and
if you go King C8 I can at least go
check Rook H7
uh uh and then
yeah even though you win the B Pawn I I
think it's quite an easy win right yeah
yeah this should be a win you're right
you're right so these two connected past
pawns white is going to drop the bottom
B7 most likely let's say King C6 Rook G7
King B6 I don't believe this is called
G6 Rook G6
Rook D6 and then
some either G4 or H4 just H4 is just
easily good enough there's no way you
hold this ever right so the punch is
looking really good here yeah but what
do you do I mean what do you do you
definitely don't play just don't
reference right you can't do anything I
think it's just over I think it's just
clearly a losing position basically
just clearly a losing position
I mean maybe you have to play Rook d8
but uh one of the things that I
definitely have understood from studying
very true king games is that you don't
want to play Passive so it's very
important to have action pieces the king
and the Rook because it's pretty obvious
they're your only pieces on the board so
if you play something like Rook d8 it's
just incredibly passive defense if
you're already down a pawn so I guess
you have to try this King seat King D7
King C sex and
matters just will be lost
yeah and of course if Jan wins this that
will tie the match now remember guys
that at the moment they do not play an
Armageddon so they will get one point
each
for the standings if janapomnishi does
indeed
win this very winning end game so
they'll just get one point each and then
there's the second mini match that will
come up in a very short while Abdul
saturov is he gonna continue steam
rolling this field it looks like it to
me I mean this is just Abdul satorov's
world at the moment look at this
position it looks exactly like Nakamura
against for the Sea of game one
right no I mean this is pretty much the
position they agreed to draw right I
mean they didn't have the pawn on A6 and
about something like this with the
Knight on G3 Knight G6 or something like
this they agree to draw
but it was a bit different right because
for sure
you know here white has got the Outpost
um Black's King is in big danger
so this feels like a completely
different situation
you're right to come compared to that to
that first game
um
so
queen of three okay I think the big idea
is Queen H5 uh or Knight E5 you just uh
open the space for other pieces the
Queens get the getting ready to jump to
H5
so update is just not even showing any
signs to slow down
yeah he's he's just a beast basically
that he is he's he's he's just far too
strong
can we go back for an 18 year old do we
go back to the game of the round so far
I mean this craziness yeah oh
did this happen
wow okay well
the bar is in the middle so blah blah
things that this is holdable but just
let's just slowly enjoy it where was
this here
yeah Jack oh there's really four
obviously we missed that
that's how it how they got here I have
no idea if it's good but that's how they
got here well it looks yeah it looks as
though feather save is actually done
particularly well right it looked as
though he was in incredible danger and
now this doesn't look worse for white I
mean Knight F4 can you just go you've
got lots of moves you can even go Knight
D3 here and the pawn ending is probably
the rook and pawn ending is probably
holdable here you would think probably
yeah yeah you're right yeah so 93 ctex
although black is still a bit active a
bit more active
yeah like you you want to like you're
not in love with it I mean you can go
King G3 this is the other movie One
Queen sorry
I was saving this I'm saving this yeah
yeah you notice that this is beautiful
this is beautiful no because here I was
I was obviously
um I was looking at 92 check first
always look
for the uh
yeah 92 check King takes G2 was okay but
G1 Queen I've landed which is yeah
yeah no of course this is played and uh
I don't see a real
like Rook A4 Kint HD2 Rook D4 I have
rookie one very important activating yep
it's probably for the song Oh no
actually I go Rook D1 sorry how big your
pun I'll go Rook D1 there I think for
the safe most likely is just gonna drop
the pawn at some point to activate the
Rook because once again we have this
discussion uh about the peace activity
which we started in the game of
nipponishi against Wesley so is that you
always want to have your pieces active
and I don't think that feather CF is
going to keep the Rook on B1 just keep
the pot on B2 so he's too strong to do
that he's just gonna drop the pawn on
beat up he has to but activate it and
software is going to be a draw
could very well be here
or I I think B4 probably also is a
playable home so why give up a poem when
you
can keep it
yeah this is this is going to be a draw
let's go back to Magnus let's do it
uh uh and what is going on
um Magnus Carlson's game
seems to be
we are only getting the right position
yeah on the on the camera
foreign
wow okay six seconds and he's he's got
four moves to make he's not gonna make
it
I mean he's he's dead lost anyway yeah
the queen is missing right yeah I mean
he's he's he's got this Pawn on A3 which
is the only thing keeping him alive at
the moment but yeah you would think that
if this Pawn is uh is taken then he's
then he you know he's got no chance
uh move 29 let's
let's see here I think he's probably
gonna make it just
four seconds okay probably
um blue Bob is not gonna flag he just
needs to make one more move but it's not
gonna help him we need three probably is
not very good but I think something like
Bishop B5 or Bishop C4 this should be
interesting uh King F1 King F1 looks
good just holding the bishop
and again I mean Magnus is probably
making sure that this Pawn on A3 is not
going too far then he would love to King
of one that's nice that's true
and some Bishop E1 that's it Bishop E1
you eliminate the Knight on B4 Bishop B1
is on the board yeah some final checks
now this game is over no no Queen takes
A2 and he resigns now
Matthias does not continue here
yeah
just one or two out
yeah just one check though and
a blowout victory for Magnus against
Matisse bluebound in their first match
of the day and uh if that's anything to
go by uh big problems ahead for Matthias
he needs to find a way to regroup
real quick because uh wow he he wasn't
even close
in those games he was not even
close to getting somewhere
right let's go back to abdicator off
this game all right yes I was looking at
nepomish against Wesley so but okay we
can go down the satoroff
um
[Music]
great position once again nothing has
changed extra Pawn
uh G5 seems to be a desperation move by
greterson I think you can just uh
take on F7 take on a five on this wait
can I can I win this by the way there
should be many ways to win this
thanks click on F7 take on G5 maybe not
ah no F4 sorry I'm blundering F4 I I
tried to calculate this
no I should be winning this yeah I
should be winning this
I'm blundering everything of course
outside passports should deal seal the
deal for white you trade the h-bomb for
that pawn this king is going to take
everything to the Queens yeah so I think
for up the sator of this is piece of
cake I mean he's just uh choosing
between Queen F7 and Rook F5 Queen F5
maybe yeah queen of five also is uh
pretty much the same as Queen of seven
so you just calculate the pawning game
he's gonna do it
yeah
very very good stuff uh and let's go to
that napoleonishi game because you you
said it was interesting doesn't look
interesting to me looks like the easiest
win known to man you can even just
uh just uh win this B3 Pawn you have two
extra pawns get h8 Queen next is sorry
I'm looking at the board oh there's
already a different position yeah yeah
there's a there's a delay but actually I
think it's just gonna be over I think
Yan is gonna take this one straight away
and Wesley so unable to just make a draw
to win sometimes that's the hardest
thing to do right you only need a draw
to win a match
psychologically very very tricky just to
make a draw
so all right
so I'm really only yeah so this this
yeah my apologies did this many round
yeah was a bit even more exciting than
the previous one I mean with all the
excitement that happened yesterday I
think we got off a bit slow start in the
first round although three decisive
games but then things just exploded
right uh nakamura's gave against for the
safe and these crazy lies of nepomanishi
against Wesley so here you see that
Westlake has resigned uh really
difficult to choose from
um game after round but so far I was
most impressed Lawrence by this uh
Knight XMD to move by Hikaru
well let's certainly move the ram we're
going to come onto that as we wait for
the uh for that for that game to finish
let's go to feta save against Nakamura
because I think the abdisaster off game
is just uh absolutely clear-cut
uh and
yes so hikara is still pressing because
the Rook on B4 is really uh applying
serious pressure on the bottom B2 yes I
don't think we have to be full that this
is a draw uh just because the bar says
it's equal there's an equal amount of
Pawns black and easily applied pressure
so the big question is can you play
King G5
trying to activate your king trying to
get to the pawn on H5 but after King G5
there could be H4 so this Rook does a
wonderful job protecting the opponent H4
attacking this Pawn
and white always needs to carefully
calculate but probably this is just a
draw Rook G4 Rook B2 Rook H4
unfortunately but yeah probably
being the right word right yeah probably
yeah
foreign
usually a lot of trouble starts when you
start to play Passive so whenever you
have a choice
go actively active try to play Act of
King G5 come on Vladimir of course by
the way if FedEx magically wins this
four white wins
will be the result in this round four
white wins a clean sweep for white which
is very very rare
um but it's not gonna happen right it's
not gonna happen I wouldn't have thought
so Nakamura is far too good
far too good unless he gets way too
optimistic here I just don't see a
Universe in which he
uh does this basically now for the save
you can you can see by his body language
he's just double checking that the end
game he's making sure he can enter the
opponent game because after Rook G4 you
have to carefully calculate take stakes
and King E5
this also you have to calculate right
can I do this Maybe by some miracle by
some miracle maybe black can do this
D3 King F4 you put the King on oh wow I
blew it what a surprise I thought H4 and
I'm queening with check but actually
yeah you're just King F3 King D3 and
you're in time right I mean whatever but
but the big point is of course you you
want to talk like this so when you're
entering a boarding game and that's why
you see that Rook G4 is what uh feather
save he already raised the cat he wanted
to make a move and this is by the way
very common thing at the professional
level you raise the card you don't touch
the piece and it's like a double check I
mean are you sure are you sure you could
play Rook G4 so I'm pretty sure that
he's gonna play but he does
and photo save looking very confident
these guys have played a lot online as
well let's also remember in a lot on
chess.com
title Tuesdays other events I'm not sure
how much 960 they've played against each
other but for sure they aren't both
understanded
this should this should be a draw
right so both sides got past pawns Maybe
some practical chances for black because
he can try to get to the pawn on D3
instead like Indie 5 V5 try to attack it
but I don't see how white is ever gonna
risk to lose this with by just pushing
for the H Pawn even if the pawn drops
for example I push forward this Pawn I
dropped the spawn I trade the H Pawn for
the B Pawn and we enter just a
theoretical Rook end game uh where the
soul leap on
and The Rook end game is not going to
help black so of this level
I think this is not even a queen's end
game right in the Roxane game it's
much much more
uh easier to make a draw
yep totally agree I think this is uh one
of those ones which you know I think
just for to say it's just too good to
ruin this one effectively
King E5 I like this technique by uh by
Hikaru because he's hiding the king from
checks but
it does feel like it's not going to be
enough if you're shouldering the king
it's a nice showing of
uh just uh understanding of the chess
and games for example something like a
check and King H6 and he achieves
something which is not even clear what
exactly he achieves because like you
said Lawrence part of B4 is too far away
right I mean
yeah there's just nothing to be done so
he's just looking for some final tricks
um being such a resourceful player
I'm not sure if Hikaru suspects that he
was winning
before I think he probably does I think
he's probably going to be a little upset
with himself because when you play 962
the king is open there you you do feel
as though there should be something here
but alas you know can I show it once
again so foreign
position here so this is this was the
moment all of this crazy uh opening
which started with feather save just
sacrificing the piece just like that
King C8 what a study moved by Hikaru and
after Rook B4 another blow Knight XMD
too
it's just absolutely incredible chance
of the highest level after F3 Queen E3
apparently there was a win somewhere for
Hikaru Rook d8 Rook D4 and I guess
Queenie 3 was the Bronk
Direction and
yeah for the safe was very accurate to
hold this to a draw and now despite the
American grandmaster's best efforts this
position can't be one
yeah
but who said that draws captive is
boring right they're not boring eggs of
course they're not boring
uh especially when Hikaru is involved
and look at this King F6 but I think we
might get a repetition here Rook f8 King
E5 Rook B8 uh we could we could get a
legitimate repetition in this position
here
could being the operative word of course
right
I think also King H7 is
a move I I don't see how black is going
to make a progress gear so maybe his
idea
do you think nah no no okay I don't know
I mean maybe both of them are playing
for the win
yeah the
I've seen stranger things they're both
very optimistic players so yeah sure I
mean you need a lot of optimism and also
I think Lawrence this is uh a battle of
psychology right you need to
um
make a draw I mean if you're making a
draw you're making a draw from the
position of strength it's like I'm the
one who is calling the shots not you
right and we are going to agree to draw
under my terms not under your terms and
exactly things like this sometimes
remain in your head and you're thinking
about it and having some sort of a
psychological dominance is quite
important because I mean in in chess who
was it I mean maybe you did Polgar or
somebody else I mean many experts said
it chess is satellite 30 even 40 percent
uh percent psychology
right so you need these moments like
this even this feels like a dead draw
this is a match situation so you won't
apply as much pressure as you can on
your opponent so that maybe he fault or
not in this game but in the match later
and it I mean is it even more than I
mean look at this position they have now
I mean they're really fighting here I
mean this is this is this is fighting
stuff
right
I mean probably not right but at the
same time
I I'm I'll be honest with you
I'm kind of surprised that the position
I mean the game is still going on I
thought they would have repeated a lot
earlier I think the game is going to
finish as soon as Kikar is going to
start to shake head so that that's
that's a good sign
yes that's also possible
that's also possible
now feather save looks incredibly
relaxed
checking final tricks
um probably it's a good idea for white
not to take the pawn
because of some background issues
which can't be done
I think he's just checking uh H7 some
checks maybe something like this H7
check it here just making sure you know
uh is my king not being cut off maybe
something like King F6 and he knows it's
a draw but I think he's just looking for
uh the most clean way to draw this
that's it so he's not looking for a move
how to make a rock he's just not looking
for the most clean way so I think he
founded king of Faith the King has to
escape from the corner anyway
but Hikaru if you look at the video I
mean he really is kind of trying here
it's it's quite impressive
it's quite impressive I mean he he's not
just I mean he I think he he he unders
yeah King he's going king of six now so
I mean it's it's kind of it's kind of
done but
uh
yeah
I think we get the repetition now so I
think it's
one of the greatest games so far
Lawrence right yes absolutely a very
nice game
a very nice game if I have to choose a
game so far in this Tournament of all of
the games I would name this one it
doesn't matter it finished in a draw it
was really uh amazing and it just
doesn't take one player it's two players
and it was feather safe right to play
it's 94 95 97 it was Hikaru who
sacrificed the pawn then it was for the
safe who sacrificed the peace that it
was Hikaru who's sacrificed and I just
you just make a popcorn you watch it
yeah
fantastic stuff
and I think we're going to get a
resolution King G5 though so actually
Hikaru is saying well your king is cut
on the back rank if I can
somehow magically
get close but I just don't see it King
F5 King Y8 and then actually rugby five
and rookie five will exist so there is
no serious
uh no no chance here
advantage
that's it nothing else I mean yeah okay
seven and now he's gonna play like
Rook Rook B6 yeah and he threatens D5
now and if King F5 then you go Rook B5
check and rookie five
oh there's just no chance yeah or Rook
D6 I mean it's just
okay shaking his head there comes the
shaking yeah yeah the shaking is now
that means the game is about to finish
yeah yes exactly
I mean Hikaru is such an amazing fighter
right normally absolutely uh
a professional player probably would
agree to draw something like I don't
know 20 20 moves ago he keeps finding
these resources and that's why he's one
of the best players in the world he
finds these resources he sets some
problems
and sometimes
it just works
yeah totally agree
uh also feathers if it's slightly low on
the clock and that's also one of the
reasons why uh Hikaru wants to track his
charge there's no risk for him of course
that what king is slightly disconnected
but
okay let's just let's just watch it
yeah
I very much doubt this is going to go on
for much longer even the great Hikaru
Nakamura I think is going to struggle to
find resources
here and uh
yeah
I'm Rook D6 the move you said
good enough
for sure
absolutely good enough and
yeah Rook H7
doesn't change much you can play pretty
much any legal Mark here
Kingda just
Rook D7 also good enough calm I wouldn't
have ever played that move but it's
probably good enough because you get the
thing off the back it's a bit weird move
but I guess it is
I mean you could just wait and do
nothing but okay I guess
there's like million ways to play it
uh Rook H4 King E7 you just can't get to
the pawn on D4 I think even white can
just play D5 right at some point okay
there you go it's gonna be Kings it's
gonna be Kings right
yeah just he's thinking about E5 or King
E4 I don't know quite quite why which
one he's thinking about which is look at
another Slayer look at that oh you're
smiling what are you doing here
exactly
nice all right
that brings us to
the end of game two let's have a look at
the scoreboards and see how these
matches the first of these matches
have finished up today and we can see
uh we can see here that uh in the first
match Abdul satoro blows gretison out
two nothing easy work for the reigning
uh Olympiad and European rapid champion
salvages
miraculously a
very very precarious situation against
Wesley so by winning game two on demand
Carlson breezes through Matthias
Bluebell Matthias never really in it
ended in a very uh entertaining 1-1 draw
but it was um yes it was it was very
very entertaining indeed lots of lots of
action
and uh what we're gonna do now is we are
going to remind you guys of course of uh
another important
uh tournament going on it is the
chess.com Global Championship taking
place in Toronto the live finals
beginning on Wednesday November the 2nd
500 000 on the line who will win it the
biggest prize in chess history from an
online tournament as far as I can tell
we've seen tons of upsets in the
tournament so far could really be anyone
who is going to win it and we're gonna
have special commentary and streaming
right here on chess.com with the
legendary
World Championship runner-up somebody I
used to work with the very dear friend
Grandma Fabiana caruana uh remember to
check that out
we are going to be back for the second
matches of the Fisher random World
Championship brought to you by Brave
and
if anything's uh if the first rounds
anything to go by we're gonna see a lot
of great action in the second round of
matches
see you all very soon see you in a bit
the only thing better than chess is more
chess so don't miss a moment of the
Fisher random World Championship or the
women's candidates we will be Squad
streaming both events so you don't have
to pick just one can we simply click
this button at the bottom of our channel
to watch multiple events at once click
again to switch back to a single screen
don't miss a moment of top level chess
with Squad streaming on twitch.tv chess
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to chess.com's coverage of
the Fisher random chess championships
brought to you by Brave we've just seen
the first set of matches and the second
set of matches are coming up in a moment
before we go there though we're going to
bring you the brave move of the day and
our tours uh which move have you gone
for
for today
you know Lawrence actually I would love
to rename it as the bravest sequence of
today because it's not just one move
it's entire sequence of the move I mean
it's King C8 I mean actually it goes
before when feather save sacrifice this
piece but okay technically it's the very
beautiful not xondito and again it's not
just even a move it's entire sequence
what happens after it because I think
it's pretty obvious that Narito Bishop
C5 is bad news for white but the big
idea actually is revealed that after
King D2 F3 white has limited options to
respond
yeah because the king is in the middle
of the board
uh and in big danger basically uh so
what actually happened because we kind
of missed it didn't we
um right so we were only discussing King
U1 right and after King you won there
was this amazing Queen E5 resource the
big point is black is traveling with a
Checkmate and if you play Queen E3
Bishop takes and C5 is a very classical
internet so check because the White
Queen on E5 is still under attack but of
course feather safe was able to pick up
the best defense Queen E3 check Rook d8
check was played by Nakamura and after
Rook D4 worked if here yeah here
apparently Queen E3 was a mistake by
Nakamura because the mighty engines say
that Bishop takes in the E4 have to be
played and after Bishop D4 Queen G2
black is enjoying a very large Advantage
if not winning
right so a missed there by Nakamura but
still Knight takes D2 the vision
for such a move I mean it's it's it's
truly special isn't it it's just
it's just very very I mean Hikaru just
to you know it's a it's a Hikaru move as
well uh a shame he he wasn't able to to
use it to finish to finish it off and he
only draws the first match he'll be
looking to improve on that in the second
game let's have a look at the results
from the first round right so here we
are seeing that uh Abdul sator of Swept
Away greterson who was putting up a
decent resistance at least in the
opening phase but then the skills of the
young uzbeki Grandmaster appear to be
higher Magnus Carlsen uh also won a very
convincing match against Matthias
blowbomb to zero there was little that
the German grams around the reigning
European Champion could do Wesley
sawyanna she I don't know about you
Lawrence but I felt that this was
probably a deserved draw because uh
nipomanushi blew away which appeared to
be quite Jewish Queen end game in game
one then came back and won The Rook end
game and finally the very exciting uh
game we just talked about hikarnak or
against Vladimir for the safe the first
game was not really exciting the second
was one of the best I've ever seen in
just 960 still 1-1 and a deserved equal
in the match
foreign
you know
of hard fought bout and we're expecting
much more of that let's have a look at
the uh standings uh those are the scores
but here are the standings for each
group
and we can see in group a abdusetorov
absolutely running away with things at
the moment just blinding chess crushing
his opponent's left right and Center
Wesley so yeah the promise you way off
the pace
it looks as though there's going to be a
battle for second there remember the top
two go through to the next stage of the
competition so it looks as though that
is where uh the the action is really
going to take place in that group gret
arson the local favorite great guy very
talented player just not good enough to
keep up with these guys and in group b
well this is a real dogfight Hikaru
Nakamura on five Magnus Carlson on four
feta save on three again the bottom
scene blue balm just not really
able to keep Pace he's got blown out by
Magnus pretty seriously today already I
expect much more of the same uh in the
in the next portion Magnus looks focused
Magnus looks good uh blue bam is just
not able to deal with with the fresh
positions and deal with magnus's genius
so
in that group it really does look like a
battle for second fair to say is still
very much in it of course so you know
we'll see what happens there yeah it's
gonna be pretty tough pretty tough for
him because two points ahead and
essentially for for the safe to try to
qualify for The Knockout stages he has
to overtake the reigning world champion
Magnus Carlsen very very tough group but
it is what it is and actually you know
Laurence if I would have to choose I
would say Obviously which is pretty
obvious by looking at the rankings most
likely it's going to be a very big fight
for the second qualifier in the group a
Wesley so against the Army because of
the sator of he just can't be stopped
yeah abdicatorov is just incredibly
strong here are the matches again well
it's just a rematch of the first set so
abductor of grasshason
Wesley so Magnus Carlson bluebound
feather save against Hikaru Nakamura
and uh with all of that said I believe
now we're gonna go for another very
quick commercial break don't go anywhere
it's gonna be in your position right and
there's going to be a new position that
we're going to have a look at in a
moment but join us in just a short
moment when we see the new position for
round two
have you come to play
pay your five dollars and get the chair
how are you
my name is Jude Acres just has given me
a life in that chess table which evolved
to a place where no one wanted to be has
totally given me a world
you might cry about all things that
happened to me as a kid don't cry I
sailed through everything the moment I
found the first book of Chess By Joseph
Plumbing I was gone and I bought a
plastic chess set in a drugstore
um ESL company with a little manual by
Frank J Marshall the legendary
Grandmaster I put it on my bed spread
and it gave off raise I was gone gone
for gone and I it literally will keep
you alive if nothing else is going right
just has the power to literally as to
watch said make people happy
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
coverage of the Fisher random chess
championships brought to you by Brave
uh we are back now for the second set
of games today before we go there though
we're gonna get a live shot of the
playing haul because it's now time to do
the big reveal of the position
for the second round
oh
right
so we have a position
um uh where I'm not even properly
sure how to announce it but it looks
quite close to the previous round except
the Oddity here you see it on the screen
is now the white king is stuck uh the
king side right so we have once again
the Rooks on every side of the king so
it's not going to be easy for white once
again to make a whatever Castle right so
again we are going to have an option to
make a very short long cost or long
Castle short whatever no wait it's
actually
the long Castle will be very long the
king will go from G1 to C1 a very very
long Castle India
Lindy
um so what do you think about this
position what else kind of Screams out
at you here as a I think it's pretty
interesting that uh probably one of the
players is going to play something like
H4 H5 well I'm not not a big expert of
just 960 starting pattern study honestly
but I think this is a an interesting way
to bring the rook in the game
uh because it also allows you to apply
some pressure and also black can't sort
of immediately challenge The Rook at
least I've seen uh some possessions like
this when The Rook is on on uh in some
fishing random positions on A4 that
sometimes they start by playing this A4
A5 rook and a one King on B1 I've seen
that this is a very common thing
probably
B4 or B3 C4 could be a choice as well to
activate this bishop
so yeah I was going to say B3 looks like
a very natural move to me to to to
activate the bishop yeah or B4 as you
said yes but but before it would leave
the C4 Square unprotected maybe there's
something like d596 and you're gonna
have some problems uh to follow up with
uh with the C4 so most likely it's going
to be C4 B3 so that will be the the
normal continuation but then again I
mean probably you can play in the center
something like D4 93 or E4 whatever uh
F4 probably is not going to happen
because that weakens the King For No
Good Reason and maybe at some point
white indeed is gonna or white or black
is gonna include this H4 H5 that would
be my
uh best guess really
yes yes I can see an H Pawn being lifted
um I can't see an early night move
doesn't really make sense to me I think
C4 is actually the move I would go for
as white here just to activate the queen
um and as you said I like C4 B3 because
then I've got that King side pressure
um so that's that's very interesting
let's put it this way I think at least
two games are going to start with C4
that's my prediction
yes that could very well happen maybe
one of them is going to play B3 and
another one is going to start with
something like
E4 or D4
so C4 makes perfect sense
now of course the players also get a
chance to review this I believe they
have 15 minutes
I believe that's the
time allotted they have to study this
position do you think they put it on an
engine do you think they discuss it with
a coach like I know for example Peter
heiner Nielsen is there with Magnus
Carlson
so it would make sense that they're
having a you know a juice or a water and
discussing
this position or do you think they use a
computer I'm not sure if it's allowed to
use any help during those 15 minutes to
be honest it could be could be but I
don't think it really will matter
because again you can't really prepare
for a lot so for example you switch on
the engine we see the bar bar sets for
white to 0.4 and the best move at at
least according to the engine is B3 I I
don't really know how it how it helps
you right so maybe yes just some generic
ideas I think that what they're trying
to do during these 50 minutes Lawrence
as you said they're trying to milk out
all of these typical Maneuvers I mean
with which pieces I'm probably gonna
start so if I play something like B3 C4
how exactly approximately I'm going to
develop my king size pieces I'm pretty
sure that all of the players already
have noticed the idea to play H4 H5 or
H5 H4 from the blacks perspective and
then they're just trying to you know
gather all of this
in one package so that it's immediately
there for an immediate use
totally totally makes sense to me
uh what do you think about the actual
chances for some of the underdogs
artists we've seen some players
really have a have a very tough time
right
uh do you do you see any hope for the
underdogs in this round no hope for
qualifying but I do see hope for at
least a decent mini match I mean they
should strike at some point because they
have nothing to lose they have no
probably
false hopes that they're gonna outlay
Magnus Carlson hikarnakamura and qualify
for the
for The Knockout stage they're just
enjoying their time and also I think
that for example blue bomb was
completely outplayed but he knows he's
playing against the best player in the
history of Chess right and uh he's doing
the best he can I'm pretty sure that
he's gonna him and uh hell uh my
apologies uh gretelson that they're
gonna show the best they can do and at
least win a game so that would be my
prediction that definitely they're gonna
win one game at least
okay I'm gonna say that I don't think
gretzen is actually going to win a game
I think uh address satorov I think the
the confidence that he has I think that
the uh the the level he's playing at I
think choppy as he's uh more uh uh
commonly known amongst friends I think
he's in he's in big trouble uh like
really serious trouble I also see
absolutely no chance for matteus
bluebound to even get uh half of I I
actually don't think he's getting half I
think he's feeling totally overwhelmed
with Magnus uh Magnus looks like he
wants to secure the you know the top
spot of this group because he's not top
yet he understands he has to do a bit
more so
you know I I actually
feel just by watching that first round
blue bum brettason with the big zero as
for the other matches
total coin flips to me I don't see
uh it clearly whatsoever an apologies so
too close fair to say I'm Nakamura also
he looked as I would Hikaru just got a
little bit but better save so
resourceful uh so could go either way
Group B is extremely interesting to me
uh with this uh
um with this Dynamic at the moment with
Nakamura Carlson fetise of all Fighting
if fedexv wins it's going to be
absolutely huge by the way if feder save
wins it's going to be massive because
you know suddenly he's got real chances
so right you see the group b
and uh yeah I think definitely you him
against Nakamura this is going to be one
of the most exciting matches because we
already discussed this they're one of
the some of the most creative players
here and it just doesn't take any
special invitation the go for a really
crazy game so that's definitely
something that we should look forward to
and here we can see as we already
discussed before the group standings of
the sator of three-point lead which is
pretty huge but again to remind you dear
viewers the tournament regulations is
that they're the so-called mini matches
and every mini-match gives the winner
two points right so you win one match
against the leader and essentially
the margin is not so great anymore
absolutely and let's just remind
everybody what they're playing for at
the moment it's uh the group stage of
this tournament two groups
tomorrow will be the final day of the
group stage the first two qualify for
the next phase of the tournament so The
Knockout stage of the tournament also
remember guys this is not
small Friars a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars for the winner
uh you know that's a lot of money uh and
uh that's a lot to fight for for these
guys
um so
you know I see real fights going in here
uh for uh yeah
uh for the remainder of this yeah or I
mean even all the prizes exactly all the
prizes are
are very very uh substantial so
we'll see what happens
but uh certainly a lot to play for and
you can see their prize distribution
look at this even a nice Payday for you
know somebody like blue balm or or uh
you know uh some of uh somebody like uh
gretas and the local we were talking
before about you know do Icelandic
players get a stipend
etc etc
uh this is you know a lot of money to
any
um let's say
not uh to put this for likely non-elite
grand master I mean how often does uh
somebody like uh gretelson get to play
for 30 40 000 in one form it just
doesn't happen so
a lot to play for a lot of yeah yeah I'm
sorry I also I also wanted to add here
is that these are not the only prizes
there were also some prizes although of
course significantly lower for the
qualification path right so there are a
number of ways how everybody could
participate in order to fight for the
store to play this tournament so toward
the qualifiers are playing here and uh I
I just love this right so it wasn't
really like uh
predetermined that these players are
going to play every everybody had a
chance so it was pretty difficult but uh
even I took apart although not very
successfully and uh it was really fun
and when to play
absolutely
all righty just a minute or so left we
can see a shot of the playing hole just
there
um players a bit of a Spectators as well
of course a lot of local interest chess
being
an important part of Icelandic culture
after
the influence of Bobby Fischer uh there
in the islands of course
um you know he played the let's call it
the second world championship against
Boris basket there if I'm right or am I
going completely insane I'm pretty sure
he did
uh maybe I'm going nuts no I am going
nuts what am I talking about uh he
didn't play it there uh but uh he
certainly spent a lot of time there
um after his release from prison was it
Japan I believe that he You're Gonna
Know it yes to be honest I know no I
think I think Japan
I think he I think when he was released
from well let's call it uh he was uh at
least being detained in Japan
that uh he he went to Iceland they took
him in
um of course there's famous videos of
him getting on the plane bearded and
talking about fishing random chess
actually about random chess this is what
he was doing at those times so it was uh
very very interesting indeed
big connection and maybe it's actually
going to become a thing you know
Lawrence that is going to be always in
Iceland right so could become a
tradition so could be could be and it
would make a lot of sense as well right
that it would be like that
um so you know have you been in Iceland
yourself yes I have I've been there on
holiday I saw the auroras Borealis the
the famous lights the uh
uh it was a very special holiday
actually now that I remember it it was a
very very nice time right and a
beautiful country I was playing in 2015
European Team Championships so yes one
of the one of the best team
championships pretty much uh ever yeah
so great country great nature fun to
play chess
so perfect place to honor uh Bobby
Fisher and uh
a great Hospitality so you can see the
players are
at the board having a powership
I guess it's water
yeah this is water they have good water
there I'll give you a quick clue before
they start I've got a nice story for you
very very quickly the first day I
arrived in Iceland years ago
uh there was a huge storm and the only
way to uh to get any food was a takeaway
I ordered a Chinese Takeaway
I ordered a box two boxes of noodles
because I was with my partner at the
time two boxes of noodles and some
spring rolls
two like crackers and two Diet Cokes if
you can guess how much that cost
remember it was the middle of the storm
nobody could go out nobody could get
food nothing if you could guess how much
that costs I'll be very very uh a lot am
I am I close cost me nearly 80 Euros two
boxes of noodles and a can of Coke
welcome to Iceland
uh well it is pretty expensive over
there pretty expensive over there yes it
is absolutely
so it is what it is uh
okay all right all right uh you can see
once again Matthias uh on the screen
once again he's facing the world
champion
I'm on Wisconsin they just did and again
they're playing again
uh C4 I was right
yes
C4 you got it spot on well done
absolutely well done yeah please A4 I
could have never ever ever met my life
predicted before
wow
yeah and the bubble machine seed for
another of C4 so what did I say at least
two players are gonna play C4 I'm I'm
standing correct but it's three
not two players but what is A4 I mean
can we just can we just pull that up
because I'm looking at this position
uh if you just go to the first move and
just take it back one movie so yeah just
just just A4
so
wait that's a normal chest position
that's we're gonna have to refresh that
oh because that's not my apologies yeah
A4 on the first move in a normal chest
position is also quite dubious but in
this particular thing here
this looks
crazy to me so I don't understand it uh
why do you need to do this because first
you you have to normally fight for the
center so this is the center your
imaginary center right so everything
happens around the center A4 contributes
nothing I mean there is not even the
Rookery one right so you could argue
that you want to play Rook A3 whatever
very big idea there's just nothing so I
have a feeling this is just for the sake
of trolling a little here and again
sending some sort of a psychological
message over to the American grams or
come out and play
it might be trolling it might not be but
it's I I simply don't understand
the move basically and as I said we just
before we were talking about they're
playing for
you know a lot of money uh there's a lot
at stake a lot of Pride and I simply
don't understand what's going on
okay but we've got a position here so
Queen C8 I mean I'm really
I I don't know I don't think I can be a
chess 960 player have a look at what
happened here artists because there's
another move that Hikaru just played
that I simply just don't understand
oh okay
um
um well the idea I guess to pay C5
because maybe yes ah okay the queen was
pinned I do understand
so you play Queen C8 I mean it does
break sort of a rule that uh you don't
want to move your queen early
uh you're supposed to move it only when
you're totally sure because uh are you
sure you want to put the command C Queen
on C8 okay B5 C5 what's going on here
I don't know but I quite like C5 there I
have to say I thought that was quite a
good little move actually
I thought that was a I thought that was
a decent attempt at least by
hikarin I kind of like black now somehow
I mean I don't love black but the queen
on eight I mean
Queen A2 is being used to defend this
Pawn
I don't mind white I mean uh White you
like white I like black
I mean you're like black I don't mind
white I mean the bishopone one is pretty
good
um white has some healthy pieces here
okay I'm not sure about the Rooker H1
pretty sure feather CF if he started
with day four he's probably gonna
continue with H4 as well exactly Knight
B3 94 95 very good control of some of
the central squares
um I
I think it's pretty okay for what
[Music]
Bishop A6 I mean
I
I just move on I just move on yeah let's
just carry on I'm not getting close to
the moves in this one like uh Bishop a63
I I don't know I mean it is looking
right but look at this there are two
games with Queens on B4 here it's very
interesting to see have a look at that
so let's start with Carlson against
Bluebell let's do that right so that was
that was an actual Gambit look at that
oh wait no sorry the snow Gambit
my mistake so C4 C5 B4 yeah the queen on
B1 protects the bottom before queen of
B1 protects the pawn on B4 Queen B4
uh
okay
looks interesting enough
yeah you know Lawrence I was looking at
this and I I was thinking can you try to
play a Gambit here but probably you know
right yeah yeah probably not I mean
there's some funny ideas like Bishop A4
at some point some problems to defend
upon on decent but okay I mean queen B4
is pretty normal Bishop tree
and uh Magnus is neutralizing the bishop
I guess
most like D4 Knight E3
this looks pretty normal to me
yeah Magnus kind of you know taking it
slow
uh Magnus with the white pieces here it
should be pointed out it is not blue bum
with the white piece there's a slides
right right the issue there with the the
graphics uh
let's go on to the other game then with
the the queen in fact they have an
identical position is that is that a a
is is that a potential error
or what are we watching here
because I'm kind of curious
oh am I looking at the same game is or I
think it's highly unlikely
but uh let's confirm that a bit later so
this it appears to be that of the
satorophagus greterson have the same
position as as you said Marcus Carson
against the Matthias bluebound
it's all Theory artists it's all Theory
I mean I mean okay it's possible it's
possible because you know you can always
gather information by looking at of uh
the board next to you and this is what I
I did once right I was go on carry on
yeah I was I was playing uh uh League
match and I got really curious about a
certain opening a certain line in an
opening I had never played before and I
thought okay I can also try to do this
right so it was a demon went and I
decided to play it although I had zero
understanding what I'm going to do next
right and uh I think that if you see
something like this happening on another
board as well you might think why not me
right but I don't think they have a lot
of time to
really
pay attention to what's happening on
other boards for example do you see
Magnus looking left and right
I don't really but I can tell you that
they have played two different moves now
as so they are they were the same
position for that long which is
obviously oh incredible
you know which is just incredible
uh so no this is pretty much incredible
yeah it is it is incredible I've never
seen that in a in in a tournament like
this let's go to Carlson again
uh sorry let's go to after Saturday
against all right
okay let's have a look here and compared
to magnus's game
uh instead of um
uh what was it instead of um
Bishop E7 Bishop F6 D4 was played in
magnus's game right now here
this is the game Carlson against Blue
bomb and here gretelson says no my
Bishop belongs on A7 so after Bishop E7
Queen F4 now we have a different CUNY
position
yeah and what do you think about this
position it looks looks it looks very
calm at the moment doesn't it basically
I think that this is a success for white
because white is uh
sort of winning the fight for the center
I can easily imagine White playing D4
uh 93 recapture on F3 with the other
night and then just
some sort of inspired either Castle Rook
B1 and short Castle or bring this rook
in the game with the H4 H5
so white is going to have a very nice
control of the center while it's not
sure well it's not very clear what black
is going to do
first opponent D7 is under attack what
do you do
well precisely you don't you you
probably don't do very much
um
it's a weird one though right it's it's
kind of strange
because after Knight F6 I might even
actually take it I mean whatever I just
take it you know I understand nothing of
just as I see a pawn I take a pawn so
please stop and prove your thing right
so what do you have
yep
why not
absolutely I mean this is definitely a
momentum ah Bishop what
oh
so in the uh Carson against Blue bomb
Bishop 6 was played immediately and now
he pushed between an A4 and now he
played yes
hmm
yeah I don't know if the what what the
tempo does there slightly strange no
idea no idea yeah
okay let's go to uh let's go to the
Nepal Mission game we got something a
little bit different a little bit more
spicy there for sure oh
Let me refresh
so a very quickly I'll start from the
starting positions here for B5 look at
that so Wesley he had different ideas
now this Knight is
not going anywhere
and what Builds an entire strategy
to keep that I don't see it where it
belongs
but I do like it but why this thing you
know one of the things that I've been
contemplating here uh
artists is
space right this is this is a theme I I
start to see a little bit more
uh in a lot of the games and it looks as
though certainly somebody like Jan uh
Magnus they've got they they believe
that an early space grab
is quite a crucial one somehow in this
particular
variant do you agree have you noticed
that I I again it's a very small sample
size so maybe I'm just going slightly
insane but it feels as though an early
space grab
um it seems to be the way forward I
don't know
I don't know maybe strange one huh yeah
but I love this book by Jan Lawrence I
mean uh yes there is a mentioned the
chat in the beginning which I didn't
mention there was a suggestion to play
Rook F2 and Castle short and uh I love
this move why because after F4 Yan said
he is the followers to take Rooker 4 and
after the short Castle there's actually
a very nice pressure on the bottom F7
because the bishop B3 is conveniently
applying some extra pressure as well so
that being said it makes perfect sense
for Wesley close the position with E4 so
that the Rooker F1 is staring at a pawn
but
I mean there's definitely a room for
improvisation here
oh
okay very very strange
okay I guess 96 is Bishop F6 so
I think neponishi is just secure on the
queen side so that in in this position
he doesn't have to worry about creating
a passport for black see like cedex and
now now Lawrence this is the moment the
truth do you play G4 or you don't
you're asking me yeah uh
uh I probably do
well maybe not maybe 92 is March
mortgage I mean I love White's position
though I mean I just this just looks
like white has got all the trumps in
this position all of the
uh uh all of the advantages basically
I don't know if you get the same feeling
that's that's my feeling here I I do I
do because I have the greatest respect
for whites Bishops I see that white can
create something interesting at a king
side okay maybe not G4 right but
actually G4 makes perfect sense because
you free the Knight only one
to G2 um
presumably it goes somewhere after that
but of course you can always just occupy
the D4 squares into like Knight c294
and
but again we are going to be back to G4
I guess because the Rooker H1 is not
doing anything
G4 looks completely natural to my eyes I
really like it and I'm I'm sure it's on
um the punisher's radar as well
uh so very interesting stuff uh
do we move on we can move on I I I'm I'm
a bit let's go back to feder save
against Nakamura because that could be
that could get interesting
oh this is a very normal position where
white has
a perfect normalcy achieved and black is
slightly suffering because the Knight 28
is not doing anything there's just no
good squares for the night uh there
might be some issues with the spin so E4
I think already is a direct threat
and maybe also C4
some sort of file what is it
English opening ideas I think Hikaru
here is lovely suffering I don't care
what the bar is saying I think he's
slightly worse here
um
just by looking yeah maybe slightly it
doesn't look like a lot though yeah it
doesn't feel like a lot right but it
doesn't feel like equality as well so I
would definitely choose why so E4 is a
threat the queen on
Queen needs to be protected I guess
Knight C7 is the area so the how do you
play Maybe Rook C8 maybe Rook C6
and
maybe that's called black claims
equality yeah
green F7 okay that's what I told you
Lawrence that's what I told you I mean
when I've been playing against Hikari
it's just impossible oh
figure out what he's thinking right so
again I'm looking at this position
imagine I'm playing as Hikaru I'm
thinking okay Rook C8 I'm gonna play
Queen B3 I'm gonna play E4 I'm gonna
play something boom he plays Queen of
sun right yes he just just don't expect
it so that's what I said I really meant
that I mean he just thinks differently
well it makes sense it makes sense
perfectly makes sense protects the queen
the napoleonishi matches is really
shaping up to be very very interesting
uh we're gonna leave it just a short
while longer I would say uh because I
think it's it's gonna
uh it's gonna explode pretty soon Magnus
got everything under control for the
serve quite quite abdusatorov also very
very I like how he keeps control
you know against these guys it's it's
very very impressive
um
so I'll let I'll let you decide where to
go where do you want to go
I sort of already chose uh Marcus's game
against uh blue ball because
um that's the one what we have on the
screen as well
and uh
now blue bump just decided to play 96
again I think he has simply a worse
position after the opening because I
mean okay it's a great uh original
placement of the pieces but again you
need to have some sort of a pawn play
and he doesn't have any so you look at
the position
um
what he has managed to grab the center
and he has some support with the bottom
E3 while black has what
so E5 no maybe B5 maybe that's why he
played Knight E6 to play B5
which should be
maybe he goes after the pawn 95.
but I definitely prefer white absolutely
no it it just feels a lot a lot more
natural right for white the just the the
central control uh you know the the
three pawns there c4d4 E3 are nicely
restricting the black pieces I can
imagine Magnus slowly improving here I
don't think this is a position where you
go completely you know insane I can
imagine moves like uh you know
five C5 that that one I'm slightly
surprised by I I have to say I'm
slightly surprised by it
so it doesn't make yeah so he wants to
get that out on C5 the other night goes
to B3 so among this play is a very
logical chess so I mean he's just
seeing things further than we are and he
spots that upon on D7 potentially makes
it a Target and if black is going to
play Knight A5 why don't they play C5
immediately but you know Lawrence I was
looking at this uh I tried to make work
Knight F4 because I felt that Knight F4
Knight H5 with a bishop on A1 is
pretty decent idea but I tried to figure
out what happens after G6 right and
maybe there's nothing but I was looking
for some 93 yeah you want to be yes yeah
that's that's what that was what was my
thought process but uh C5 is a very
logical move
but strange maybe maybe another four was
a bit more energetic
can we go back to the napomnia game
because a knight has landed on F5 and we
love it when a night lands on F5 that's
well I love it when a night lands on
it
um
is it as threatening as it looks though
maybe it's just not maybe this is just
not that spectacular for white I you
know I get excited when I land I mean
maybe it's because I don't know how to
defend and actually the truth is when
any anybody puts a knight on F5 against
me I just lose
um
maybe that's the truth I just get
excited when I see an eye on F5 but uh
still looks a little bit tricky now has
the black king has not castled yet but
the black Rook has moved so the move
castles shorts still exists right but I
think even age five is looking extremely
reasonable because I was I was looking
at G6 tried to secure the G7 Square for
the king and push away this annoying
Knight but after Knight H6 King G7 I'm a
bit too lazy to calculate I mean maybe
maybe there's some crazy on SPG for I
mean I don't know I mean G4 King H6 G5
King G7 and somehow somehow I capitalize
on this pin right I mean I was very
quickly to suggest that with some F5
whatever you know I I can't properly
calculate but then I see that the
problem is not H6 and my idea was to H5
which stops White's intentions to play
G4 G5 at some point anyway because this
is where we have the queen in the night
I don't play G6 later so I look at this
it makes apps a lot of sense to me
mm-hmm but Wesley plays something else
yeah roxito
yeah Rook C2 going active just not not
doesn't care
he just says actually if if I if I win
this deep Pawn it's it's good news for
me
which makes a lot of sense
so does does Yan actually have anything
here
yeah that's real interesting I mean
there's at least an easy Queen D4
maybe that's the big point after Queen
the four Queen Arc here we go
97 king of Faith there's I guess nothing
we can try to show it maybe Queenie for
you protect the ball but after Queen B6
oh wait there's also Rook C4
yes Rook C4 is a very nasty move that's
a cute little idea actually very nasty
move yeah
okay if you can't play Queen D4 you can
what do you do can I play G4 or it's too
much WoW
radar he sees this I mean before you
open up the second rank you're not
you're not afraid at all huh you just
don't care it's not my game song it's
not your pieces what do you care I don't
care I love it so I can suggest funny
ideas
yeah of course you can absolutely and it
actually sort of makes sense because
uh the idea is to get to the port on G7
after 9g 3g5 there's some ideas
actually the bar says it's actually not
so bad
wow
and by the way I'm being informed that
gretasan you know I said he had no
chance
right look at this let's go to his game
apparently he's completely
winning
is that is that true because I'm looking
at this position and I don't see why why
is
why is the bar down there
so you
okay so what happened here he sacrificed
upon
this is voluntarily a voluntary Choice
by of the sator of right he didn't
blunder this he sacrificed it I mean his
idea he used to go for this Checkmate
and this is the idea which I mentioned
in the Carson's game it's not a
fortnight H5 I would be looking at this
but not at the expense of the port on C4
uh I guess it's nothing but of course
abdicator doesn't know it
he doesn't know it's nothing he thinks
he he thinks it's quite something
maybe take F3
Queen goes here
or maybe just take it
and uh if you take with the bishop I
play Knight F6 there's definitely always
some attacking ideas there has to be
some some direct problems maybe
maybe just go away with the bishop right
Bishop B7
simple as that huh yeah
but I wouldn't say it's winning I mean
take take F3
like this this looks
unclear to me so I I don't understand
maybe bishop G6 is a problem right here
actually but even this
winning
come on
yeah white is not ready for the attack
right I mean the Knight only one The
Rook on H1 don't really help
yeah so whatever happened here uh the
big question mark maybe uh goes to
abdicator of here the Knight of four
because this was a sequence that he
wanted I mean he sacrificed the pawn
and this this is what we talk about
Lawrence right that uh yes the the
professional players they tend to
overestimate they tend to give the wrong
evaluation I mean of this tutorial
blundered nothing he just treated this
position as it's a good position
apparently right and then after a couple
of goals he's going to figure out oh my
goodness what I'm doing here
let's go to napomnishi so because action
is on the board
the bar has gone berserk
oh
let's go straight there Queen E6
oh my God
what
did that just happen how is that even
possible I mean how do you blunder just
a piece just like that how do you
blunder Queen A8
this is so weird this makes no sense I
mean this is a pretty normal position H5
G6 or G shits g6h5 what the necklace
Queen C8 so Queen C8 96 you give up a
pawn for a Tempo now the opponent E4 is
under attack what did this they just did
it happen
has had a glitch in The Matrix one of
the most reliable guys
and he's he's there and and nepo's like
well what do you want from me I I think
member is just what why did you give me
a point here I don't get it
what wow absolutely
insane stuff
so there's some first result
an interest interestingly what we now
have are to us is we have the reverse of
the first
said right yeah she had to win game two
and now Wesley so has to win game two
extraordinary
some total brain lag I mean I don't
understand it but I'm I don't understand
what the Arbiters are doing there
there's some some kind of an assistance
from the Arbiters what they're asking
there I I don't understand me neither
maybe we can get some clarification on
that a bit later on very strange very
strange moment because I mean this
entire sequence it just
it just makes no sense right did he
accidentally release a can or something
he wanted to play Queen Y8 and the Beast
dropped out he landed on C8 or something
I don't get it I mean just it just makes
no sense
let's get some clarification maybe from
our team uh for the moment though Wesley
so making an inexplicable blunder
and we're gonna we're gonna find out
let's go back to
let's go back to fit to save because
this has also gotten completely out of
hand it seems
uh for the surf is definitely uh pushing
uh and um so we left it when was this
after this queen of seven odd move
so uh black is slightly struggling with
the coordination of his pieces because
the last rank is normal what you want
where you don't want to position them
take take C4 so we have some sort of uh
what is this some sort of a sicilian
great position for white
whatever right
uh very strange yeah now Hikaru is
trying to hold on and wow
D5
rookie for
Nike car is going to be suffering here
for a long long time but I guess he is
now probably thinking how to escape in
some end game four against three maybe I
guess rookie 4 Rook D5 even if white
wins The Pawn on B6
it might be not enough
but either way it's quite clear that
feather safe is the one who is pushing
and so far he's playing brilliant chess
I'm a big fan Telly honestly I mean uh
it wasn't only Lawrence it wasn't only
Hikaru who played this amazing 92 it was
the entire sequence the entire game by
Father's Day of amazing
flying of imagination from both players
so it was an absolute pleasure to watch
absolutely fantastic plan shout out also
to the chess bras for the raid thank you
so much guys uh and everybody coming
from the chess bra channel to watch this
absolutely fascinating day of Chess here
um at the
Fisher random chess championships
brought to you of course by
ourselves chess.com
and by Brave we'll talk a bit more about
them as well as the
stream continues
for the moment though uh we've got this
very interesting position now for the
save against Nakamura pure suffering as
uh you called it authors I tend to agree
this looks like just a position you
either win as white or you make a draw
very nice at this level I mean I missed
it I was concentrating on rookie four
rooksy yet of course easy easy puzzle
Rush uh so while it has two collected
passports and Hikaru the best he can do
is try to go for some Perpetual check
yeah Queen G6 queen of five for Queen H5
and pray that it's gonna be enough
maybe it is actually maybe it is I mean
the more I look at it I'm not that
convinced by why it's because Queen G3
there's Queen G3 yeah
H1 Queen H5 you have amazing
difficulties to protect the spawn
because queen of four Queen G3 oh wait I
just dropped the Rook oh my goodness
okay I see nothing so even King H1 is a
move
yeah but Queen G3 looks pretty logical
Queen G3 E4 rugby one
doesn't look good for American fans
yep
what about German fans Magnus Carlson
has got a rogue Rook on H5
uh excuse me sir what is that guy doing
up there
so he did play H4 yeah he plays Four
when it cost him a pawn so that's a
position sacrifice he sacked up it felt
like a position where he didn't need to
sack at all so it's very curious that he
decided to go for this
all right very interesting moment right
I felt that somebody might play this H
for a moment at some point but when it
costs a pawn for a tempo
okay that's a bit odd moment
Rook H5
I think Magnus is just having too much
fun here
you think he's enjoying himself huh yeah
too much
weight probably
his position might not be that good
though but difficult to say right I was
looking at his funny idea 94 but I see
that it's not working 94
uh some Bishop P4 ideas but I probably
uh I'm gonna lose this Knight right
Queen A8 and this Knight on
E2 is lost no no oh wait my
I saw that I just tested you
okay okay now now it's correct idea
right yes so
even even something like this could be
considered
to be honest Lawrence
yes it makes no sense
sorry Magnus
it makes no sense it just makes no sense
I mean why
I have no idea I don't get it
I mean okay I get the idea to sacrifice
a pawn
at some point but
for uh when you lose even a tempo
just to put the rook in H5
maybe we just don't understand chess
artists yeah we that's the problem I
just don't get it
you know
just have no idea what's going on quite
spectacular
maybe he's just trolling a little here I
don't know but uh some really inspired
shots on okay maybe modus is thinking
deeper you know when black is going to
Castle short that the Rooker H5 is
actually what you want it to be because
there's going to be some other big
attack which I don't believe it's
okay uh what else have we got going on
uh wow Hikaru is
is trying to force the draw here
in uh in a pretty uh sort of direct
F5 again a move that makes a lot of
sense because he's trying to rupture
this structure
well he's he's a tricky guy is this
Hikaru Nakamura he's very difficult so
what do you do against rookie a rookie
one he wants to play something like
Queen D2 is that what you and just
molest The Rook
right uh to apply some extra pressure
you don't think he's
being super super optimistic here do you
Hikaru but then again we saw it in the
last game where he's just trying to win
at all costs it seems like you guys
would do something right I'm not sure
what else because uh the passive defense
here is okay maybe F5 was not necessary
he could have played B5
but that thrive
also makes sense because he's exposing
the King right
Queen E5 Maybe
some check ideas Rook effect
25 I like yes
but there might be
there might be no decent follow-up
Pawn on F3 is still under attack
yeah I know
very quickly
difficult to tell difficult really
really difficult position huh to uh to
even assess
right right
so uh we'll we'll come back to that one
I think let's go to add to Saturn
because we have got absolute
Carnage on the board oh my goodness look
at that what is this position I mean it
looks like
it looks like one of my six-year-old
students is playing here with uh with
white but uh
actually the thing like is completely
winning or completely winning right yeah
it's very obvious that black is
completely winning here
I don't know whoa Knight takes F2 what
is that
that's a nice move
what is this just again
I think he just wants to go like takes
takes takes an fg4
is that what he wants and just claim
what do you need to sacrifice the Knight
attack on G4
first so we've missed some some sequence
right so okay
yeah he he went for a Desperado attack
there was some sort of uh oh there you
go 97
some sort of big attack I'm not sure why
this is even necessary
and if I play King F2
just take it
so why do you need F text and G4
I mean why can't I just like maybe he
was scared of some Queen D4
Knight B5
what about
um
I mean yeah 96 and even even something
like Queen C4 you know simplifying the
position killing the attack looks very
legit but okay but there I mean engines
approve as well so Knight of two Rook of
two and now attack on G4 I guess is also
great
like this I may maybe he wants to go
Knight E4 check first is that possible
oh maybe
maybe this is his grand plan because
Queen C1 checking Queen takes E3 is
winning
that's wow that's a brilliant point
that is a brilliant Point that's what he
wants
and now I take it
no no yeah now King E2 fg4 now the king
is on E2 and it's Bishop B7 Bishop A6 is
coming and all kinds of stuff
is uh is happening here
this is not fun so
all I can calculate uh here Lawrence is
that now it's material equality compared
to that position where I had an extra
piece
yes okay maybe this is somehow winning
due to Bishop B7
yeah yeah Bishop B7 looks crushing
wow
so that's a brilliant sequence and after
Rook V8
wait what has happened
Earth has happened
what on Earth has just happened
wait what don't tell me there's not a
phone
97.
that's it
wait okay now the five is a big move
and if I take it oh my goodness
and this is just 96 King E8 Bishop H5
even or something King King D7 Rook
you just take on B8 at the right moment
yes
wow wow this was poor copy just
no greatherson you blow it I mean he had
such a great game wow
I mean okay Knight F2 is a great move so
I mean why don't you just take the piece
on G4 right okay I understand this
entire sequence 94 here
I guess the cold move left action G4 had
to be played but I mean to be honest to
spot Lawrence from afar Bishop B7 Bishop
A6 for example in this position F takes
96 and you have to see from afar that
chill uh it's it's Bishop B7 right
yeah you can easily miss that no for
sure I mean it's very miserable but even
still
even still it's something like this
it's it's kind of I'm kind of in a State
of Shock here wow look at this I mean
this is just
brutal stuff absolutely
chess is such a brutal game
uh really is
yeah there's no no forgiving uh so you
make a make a mistake at this level
that's it you're done so when you enter
tactical complications uh one mistake
that's it but again
uh gretelson was very close to score a
victory and now he's just down a piece
with exposed King this game is not going
to continue for long and also he's down
on the clock
but what a major turnaround and for up
the sator of another
uh another great moment to score more
points and it just adds to the feeling
of invincibility right
absolutely when you when when you save
dead positions it's it's a it's a fun
feeling
it's a fun feeling especially in a big
tournament like this we've got
progresses and I I do feel for him he's
a dear friend of mine and but ultimately
you can't give these guys a chance at
the top level you just cannot do it
otherwise they will just punish you
all right what do we do do we move on
because there's I think we go to Carlson
yeah let's go to Carlson because I think
the Carlson game is is very very
interesting
um very very tense and we've got here a
close-up of bluebound and Carlson
so
what do we make of this position B take
C5 on the board I think I saw Knight C5
and mileage just continues to play like
nothing happens so he gave up the pawn
H4 and just played like nothing happened
yeah it reminds me of the time I uh
played in uh
in a in a European youth Championship I
remember
i i blundered a piece very early on sort
of moved 10 or 11. and I just said okay
I'm just going to carry on like nothing
has happened
and I did and I ended up making a
drawing he was a very strong players
actually Yuri borisek Grand Master now
um
that's okay just carry on and that's
what that's what Magnus says okay it's a
pawn a piece what does it matter just
carry on
just carry out
and he is going on after Bishop Y8 Queen
A8 9c5 Queen C6 this is the actual
possession yes
um I find it a bit odd that black hasn't
castled yet yes so the king is still
under yet so black has the option
I guess Knight C6
you don't want to create a weakness on
C6 right you take with the Knight
oh no he does take interesting D5
what is this
D5 E5 is
very strange
I guess Bishop A1 for K1
could
be and then Knight C
somewhere e five or E7 I don't know he
will survive you have to have to clock
on C6 so when you're in that trouble you
start to see ghosts right for example
sex and you could easily Miss calculate
the dx1 C6 there's gonna be something
but there's nothing I see nothing here
the the nether detail is under attack so
if you take anyone attack on Tito
so this is not uh how much this is going
to play I guess bishopay one through K1
and some sort of uh whatever move
Knight e75 something
Maybe 97.
no I'm not gonna say is slightly
overdoing things here I don't like what
he's doing
I mean we have to give him a lot of
credit for this very inspirational Pawn
sacrifice H for rubbish P4 which I kind
of don't understand why he did it I
guess he was in such a deep level
thinking that rooken H5 is compensating
the absence of the pawn because the rook
in some cases can be lifted towards
inside and then you know you're gonna
get back everything in
in interest but
it doesn't look like it
wow
crazy crazy stuff and you were right
because I said blue balm I didn't think
he had any chance at making a making a
draw but he's favorite now not to make a
draw he's actually favorite to win this
position
I mean
you know a Pawn's a pawn and I see no
danger for him
anywhere
you know so it's very curious
oh and actually Lawrence we have an
update of why Wesley so resigned and
after Queen A8 you remember this crazy
yes yes
he thought he thought he can actually
Castle
oh but he's in check that's a very
excuse and check on Yukon Castle so that
was West Virginia yeah and he thought he
can play Rook Cafe and castle and
apparently there was no castle at all
that's why this was not a blunder this
was not a brain like he just I mean
whatever I mean he thought Hereafter
Queen A8 Rook effect is a legal move but
apparently
I guess he made it I don't know but then
Arbiters kindly explained to him that uh
Rook effect can't be played if this
happens this happens so it does happen
I've seen stranger things happen but
it's kind of unusual I I mean I'm
slightly surprised that Wesley
no it is surprising no it it is
surprising it's not it's not that normal
I would say it's not that normal
um okay let's go back to the Magnus game
and some action there's a Pawn on D6 now
so what's going on here
um
I guess there's some sort for
compensation for white because the pawn
on D7 is under attack I guess you can
play four at some point but here's the
thing black is going to sacrifice it and
play Rook d8 next and then your Pawn on
D6 is under attack and the more moves
are being played the question is what do
you have for the poor Among Us
not much
yeah not much at all
okay but he's interested
yeah go on yeah no no you go no I was
gonna say you know F4 and take on D7
right
um you mean a four yeah
a four I'm not playing ig4 and after
route 97 you play here Knight C4 play
and again blue bomb in terrible time
Trouble 24 moves he still hasn't
adjusted it seems
to this
Rook d8
so I guess Magnus wants to play
Knight B to C5
I guess he also realizes his only chance
to win the game is try to surprise his
opponent in
in the time scramble but actually 50
seconds it's not so little
bit well it's six moves it's still a
complicated position so I'm not sure how
happy it it is Knight E5
this is an extremely unusual move
Rook these six black just collects the
pawn
now black is still up upon I guess
Magnus is just hoping for some counter
play but now you can take take take take
Rook A5 very difficult position to win
I think yeah I don't think I don't think
Magnus is gonna lose this to be honest
no I mean what is still active
I think Bluebell missed something here
actually it feels like
it feels like bluebound Mr shot I don't
know exactly what but in that little
sort of melee there this is okay the
game is still going on the game is still
going on this is what the engines were
saying actually by the way
the pawn drops
so but I mean this Knight G5 is not very
human it's not very human because your
first thought process in advance trouble
is to eliminate the pawn on D6 I I think
in classical just of course blue one
would pick it up if he would have
something like a couple of minutes but
when your clock is ticking you're
playing a rapid time control it's just
impossible to pick it up
interesting
all right now with G3 on the board what
an what an interesting imbalance we have
two against four and then then we've got
a a kind of outside pause Pawn I mean
what on Earth is going on here
just got extra five minutes I mean he
got at the wrong moment oh my goodness
yes he could have got the extra five
minutes where was this once again okay
that's move 25 he would have really
found it useful here these extra five
minutes now
might be not enough
A4
A4 okay
well it's quite quite obvious that
Magnus now wants a draw nothing else
from this game because that would secure
him the what would secure it would
secure nothing because
that's what I'm talking about it secures
nothing okay I guess he just wants to
make it grow
well I think so I think he's going to be
relatively happy with with a draw here
he's had a bad but I think he
experimented it didn't go quite right
and he's he's looks fairly confident
that he's going to make this draw
um what do we think about the Federal
Savings against Hikaru game
yeah let's jump over there has there
been any more action there
um
at least we are not getting any moves
so we also have this great bird's eye
view on all the games yes so here you
see that again this unfortunate finish
of Wesley uh having thought that he can
actually Castle short this is why he
lost the entire sequence was wrong
ferisev is walking
where's he walking his game's running Ah
that's a draw then another draw between
these two absolutely astonishing stuff
actually
uh because
we've had just you know
three draws basically between these
right so he didn't find the way how to
capitalize on the extra Pawn he felt his
king is too weak and it's a match
strategy I mean okay yeah draw is a draw
but there's more games against Hikaru
for sure there's more games
so he was not gonna risk it so which
game do you want to choose Lawrence
well let's go back to Carlson because
that's really the only one left isn't it
actually neponishi has beaten
still playing he is oh excuse me I
thought it was mate already I saw a king
on H5 and I thought you're right yeah
okay sorry I thought it was mate already
in it it does no no no no he's winning
he's winning yeah yes you're right
you're right okay so
okay so after I was winning let's go
back to Carlson it's really the only
game Left Of Interest
and you can see that abdisatorov has
taken his stuff
is out of here
and the
yeah we expect this one to be drawn the
problem is of course that even if Magnus
does push the pawn at any moment
Matthias bluebum can sacrifice the
Knight for the pawn and he's in no
danger at all of course he's he's never
in any danger here
so
so that's good he's gonna have to play
Knight C6 at some point the question is
which moment maybe what what if I play
it right now yeah he did six yeah yeah
like take and A6 right A6 King fate I
guess you bring your king closer King E7
King E3 King D6 and now the million
dollar question is
it's gonna win this okay it looks really
short this is actually on the board
all I showed was actually being played
because it makes perfect sense
yes
yeah
yeah it's I guess it's an individual
yeah it's gonna yeah it's gonna be a
draw for the soul reason so you need to
handle this Pawn the Black Knight cannot
remain on A7 because without the nut you
can't win the game and when you bring
the king to the bottom B6 most likely
your king side is gonna fall most likely
so Magnus is going to play something
like 94 9g5 or 93 94.9 H5 with the help
of the king with the help of the Knight
with the help of the pawn I don't think
that black is going to have the luxury
to take the pawn and be just in time
back at a king side
that's why it's intro yeah
all righty
I mean doesn't mean you can't play it
no no no of course I mean and and he
should play it uh so but it's it is
going to be a draw of that I'm pretty
confident
uh
uh all right what else have we got
going on
not much this is the only game this is
it right and I do this yeah one more one
more game
[Music]
yeah yeah and then we have the last game
of today uh and this is a really simple
draw because now for example after F6
you can take on H7 and then you can go
after King B6 or this whatever it is
yeah and they're playing it out pretty
quick and of course here
uh blue bump has no illusions that he's
gonna win this of course again the body
language says it all
but
absolutely again he had some minor
chances there was pretty much the only
mistake that Magnus did again we have to
we would have to go back maybe after the
game's gonna finish I'm going to show
you this moment yes just a small chance
indeed
indeedy
with a king on Gia this is also a draw
by the way
yeah
King anywhere is the drawer probably
right maybe not on G4 I don't know oh
yeah that's true sorry yeah I'm being a
bit uh pedantic there you're right
you're absolutely right 97
and now actually Global is securing a
draw on 95 93 yeah so that he doesn't
miss anything Magnus finishes the game
with an extra night congratulations
not enough though for Magnus Carlsen
it says blue balm with a draw with the
black pieces I'll give him some
confidence going into game two uh where
he's got a chance now with white poor
old Greta Sun just
spoiling a beautiful position
um and uh let's have a look at what
happened
in that first round well we'll get the
scores
just in a second but effectively it is
a win for episode sort of can't do
anything wrong even when he's losing
he's winning uh quite spectacular stuff
uh it's just lack of a winner if I dare
to speak I mean when you are playing
good it's great but when even luck is at
your side it just adds more confidence
and of the Satora office so super
confident at this tournament
he absolutely is
Wesley so with a misunderstanding of the
rules as far as we can tell thought he
could block a check he thought he could
do something couldn't and it was the end
of the game so uh janapomnushy uh gets
off to a great start Wesley Stone needs
to win
and we are going to uh go to a break
now of course this is the chess.com
coverage of the Fisher random chess
championships
uh brought to you by Brave we'll be back
for the second game in just a jiffy
see you
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the points King to win oh wow oh there's
no stalemate let's still wait there is
still meat but the still made the player
wins ooh if only that was real
I think I'm getting the hang of this
game I think I think I actually am
getting the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dark chest
there's some real bullet skills right
there boys this is a fast time winning
duck chess That's so exciting
oh no no no no no no slip no no no no no
no
yeah duck chess champion give me those
points baby
foreign
[Music]
and everybody and uh welcome back to the
chess.com coverage of the Fisher random
chess championships brought to you by
Brave and we're gonna have a quick look
at the scores so far in the second round
of matches today a bit more of a
balanced round Magnus Carlson drawing
with matteus blue man good performance
there by Matthias probably missed a
chance to even get the win
uh Nakamura felicev was again a really
tough one to uh to decipher looked as no
fair to say I've had great chances but
Hikaru ever so resourceful very very
difficult to beat Wesley so with a
complete meltdown and misunderstanding
of some of the rules even the best can
sometimes learn it in this new format
losing to uh
janapomnushi and Abdul satorov
with a
well a lucky win is an understatement he
was toast against uh the Local Hero
gretison but
just made a huge blunder and allowed
Abdullah if you cannot give abductor of
a tactical chance like that
meaning that Granderson is on zero
points for the day he's actually now
lost five games in a row really tough
for him and he's got black against uh
sorry he's got white now I beg your
pardon against Abdus set her off the
last game of the day coming up and
perhaps we can have a look at the scores
for each group as well that would be
great group a right
crushing what's What's Happening Here is
the door of uh I think uh yeah it's
still six points but he's having having
scored a one big three this means that
he is a ball to score eight points out
of eight so far the bomb machine Wesley
so are divided three points each but
again for Wesley's chances the previous
game took a big blow because yep that
was very very bizarre turnover for when
I should have scored his first Victory
but at the moment he's still at zero
points and as we already discussed
Nakamura Carlson are spearheading the
group b and for the safe is still within
the contention and bluebound well he is
just slightly behind
yeah let's see what these guys are
fighting for it's not just for the title
of world Fisher random chess champion
but no have a look at these prizes 150
000 US Dollars first prize 85 000 for
second 55 for third 40 25 2015 and 10
going down the list
uh you know that's serious cash even for
these guys so uh you know they're going
to be fighting tooth and nail to get
through them remember today is day two
tomorrow's day three there are two
groups and the top two from each group
go through to the next phase at the
moment in group a of course it's all
Abdul saturov but neponishi Wesley so
have got a little battle going on there
that's the key match up those two
um just slightly ahead at the moment uh
32 years old yeah we all know him by now
he played Magnus Carlson for a world
title match
uh came up short but has been given
another chance uh he played a phenomenal
tournament at the candidates winning it
with ease he'll now play ding for the
world championship title a natural
Talent
and uh defeated uh a number of top
players uh for third place in this
tournament in 2019 including farooja and
Carolina
and uh you know so talented so creative
you would expect Jan
to uh to put on a show here in group b
things are far less clear because
they're tightly packed and with the
exception of Matthias blue balm pretty
much it's a three-horse race Nakamura
fettuccv Carlson which of these players
is going to get the top two spots
is blue bomb gonna play the spoiler and
for example imagine Matthias now beats
Magnus with the white pieces all of a
sudden it's all up in the air very very
very tough little tournament
and of course thank you for everybody
tuning in
um watching us uh with your nice
comments it's a pleasure being here the
next game coming up is the last
game of today
there'll be more action tomorrow though
at the same time so we'll be back A View
From the playing Hall there archers and
looks very nice looks like a nice little
playing haul looks very oh Icelandic
I would love to be there yeah it looks
very cozy very nice atmosphere to play
chess and uh obviously we're not a nice
one
I would love to be there we have been
there and uh here we go I think the
final uh game of today is going to start
at the moment and um again the players
are facing the same opponent this time
Matthias blow bomb is going to have
white girl against Magnus Carlsen there
you see them on the screen now this is
probably gonna give uh for blow bomb
perhaps some extra confidence because uh
in the previous uh game we just were
following he did have some chances
against the world champion
and uh yeah that's all you need yep and
yeah by the way as Lauren said a big
shout out to all the viewers uh we are
watching what you're saying there thank
you for your support
some of the funny uh comments there I
like them
and I hope you're enjoying it as much as
we do we are commentators but also chess
players we are enjoying these games
really we all know
very much
and the games have kicked off and you're
I mean well done artists for kind of
guessing that in this particular
construction and once again if you've
just joined us and you've missed the
action today this is Fisher random chess
so the pieces are shuffled on the back
rank they're in 960 different versions
of that shuffle and today it seems as
though in this particular configuration
of pieces move C4 seems to be the move
of Choice by wide in the majority of
games
um I'm sorry I'm sorry yes tell me
buying a plotter here uh tell me you
know I see two possible trolling
openings
yes one of them is obviously c4a5 right
so this is like a direct resemblance to
what for the save was trying to do to
Hikaru but yes then I then I had a
glimpse what is happening in Nakamura I
guess for the Seth I remember I was
going through all the possible moves at
the opening phase and I was saying like
every single move has sort of a purpose
perhaps maybe except of f4 right because
F4 opens the king there's no need to do
that and then he current plays F4
exactly
well uh
I don't understand anything so about
about the uh the opening stage it's it's
such a mystery but that's what makes
this also very beautiful original
position how often do you have a bishop
on A5 after two moves not very often
right by the way Bishop A5 is just such
an insane move to me I just
honestly this move
just uh it's it's beautiful and feather
save is so perfect for this event
because he's so creative
uh Bishop A5 this is some some sort of
psychological warfare right because in
the first game for the sale played A4
and got a great possession now Hikaru
says if you can play against me A4 I can
play against you F4 and now F4 B3 C3 B4
just looks weird well I mean what can I
say it just looks weird it makes no
sense right I mean the bishop A1 is
stuck looking at the pawn on C3 so this
is some kind of uh
psychological warfare between these two
like they're just battling it out who is
going to be the most creative player
here today
yeah it's a battle of the artistes
Nakamura against for the same B4 Bishop
I I don't like F4 I don't I weaken my
king I don't get it it's not an
intuitive move to me at all but who am I
it's a question Hikaru Nakamura
um I much prefer your C4 and uh blue
balm
with a solid position at the moment
against Madness nothing much going on
there
and believe it or not in Abdul saturov
we have something a little bit similar
if you want to take a look at yeah
that's what we can do
oh
so the bishop is not on A5 it is on B6
but what he has done slightly better
here compared to hikaru's game
he has managed to take over the center
much better
oh you know Lawrence I I'm really I
really want to play C4 here if I could
for example white let's not have three
C4 and I just ask you a very direct
question so what are your career plans
for the bishop only one right
well I probably have to go I probably
have to go B3 right right yeah beach one
yeah
slowly slowly move it out but you're
right you're completely right this is
this is very interesting
we didn't get any of that
and that's why I guess he took on C5
so that there's no idea to play uh for
black C4 but it doesn't help for the
bishopone A1
yes it doesn't and the bishop 1 B6
stands Mighty here and I don't like what
gretison is doing here I don't like it
at all
um
yeah again I mean it's a psychology
right Lawrence yes yes you just you just
have this previous game in your mind and
again you can't really prepare to
compare the same player he was for
example uh at the start of the
tournament with ambition well prepared
rested Etc and then it gets exactly the
same player let's say at the end of a
very long day after suffering a major
loss in a completely winning position
okay maybe he didn't know it probably
somebody said okay listen I mean you can
add a completely winning position there
I'm so sorry right so it's very tough
and you have to swallow that bitter
pillow so it's it's uh very uh very very
tough sometimes to play and it really
matters when you when you play so I
think that greterson in greterson's mind
is still this uh uh previous game
yeah it's very difficult to to rebound
from from a game like that uh you you
uh you you really
uh just
you can't you can't bounce back easily
it's just you know you need the mental
toughness that's that's really only
exists I mean there are only a few
players in the world authors which can
you know I I think of players that
suffer a huge loss and can just robot
bounce back immediately uh very very few
players can just do it emotionless
uh one of those
is Fabi actually I think Fabiana Carmona
is one of the top guys in the world for
a quick bounce back
but you know right it's very tough and
White's position here looks horrible
let's go to uh where should we go should
we go to so napometershy
yeah let's let's do that let's do that
um
okay
there's a very menacing battery
yes
it is that's it
and that's it
so there's no 9g4 ideas at least not
immediately because the bishop DF
protects the net on F6 otherwise it
would be an idea right yeah
yes what do you make of this position
Lauren so I'm not I like boys sure like
up at 94 is 94 is 94 is very interesting
now it's kind of saying I don't want to
be too passive here so I'm going to hit
your queen okay so Queen C2 will be
played probably the queen doesn't Queen
E3
looks really tree yeah Queen E3 looks
interesting uh looks wrong to me looks
wrong okay yeah because I think can't
you just kick the Knight and then C4 ah
no but no D7 is hanging this is this is
very weird but he went back to C2 this
is clearly a Wesley so uh move Queen C2
much performance
yeah 1955.
yeah maybe I just have to take the
center now I don't know
deforia for example
I look at that 90.6 Bishop C6 Bishop C6
and I lose yeah rookie eight Knight F6
was my plan but vicious yeah great idea
he's cute
okay okay
um
okay so Queen C2 Knight C5
um yeah black looks pretty solid and
actually after 94 black has also ideas
to play Bishop six
which is not only depending upon on D7
but applying some counter pressure
against Anatomy 5K Edition A1 which is
not defended by the way
so it's a great move I like it so
greatly if I yeah yeah
might be a great move it might just be a
you know is white even worse now because
my Bishop feels wrong my Knight's
landing on C5
if the two Bishops start to work here
well it could just be a lot worse
Maybe
but then again I'm not sure probably
this Queenie tree will have to be played
I mean queen E3 so that I keep the
bishop because I have a feeling I want
to keep the bishop here to look at the
white king
and what do you do I guess so oh wait
it's not even under attack
there could be some Bishop G5 ideas yeah
that's what I was thinking yeah yeah
this is this is good
now now so Knight D7 doesn't work here
right
um
and yeah this is at least I see that
here neponishi has a chance to force
what to play for which Hikaru did
voluntarily right he didn't need to be
forced he just played it himself and
this is definitely an option here
so either Queenie Trio or
Queen whatever
Queen D4
I don't understand this position no no
how many times have we said that today I
don't know every game every game
it's understanding I mean it's an honest
answer right that we just don't
understand it there's a million ways to
play the song there's just no normal
pattern which applies to this possession
so we can just guess we're looking at
this we're guessing that we're pretty
good guessers normally but true
let's move on all right let's move on
let's go to something also a little bit
excited let's go to Nakamura feta seif
let's let's go there
all right all right
um
so
what is going on here
um the better one is still
wait it's actually I thought it's the
same game
uh Lawrence but also graterson is having
the bad Bishop syndrome on A1 yes this
is I mean it's just pretty sad
this position looks bad for white now
because you can never go D3 because E3
is hanging so how do you actually get
your pieces out here as white
like well the bishop on A1 is just Dead
Forever
I mean until you play d3c4 so maybe you
have to start with the idea you need to
secure the pawn on E3 I mean how do you
do it oh it's C1 giveaway what a rookie
one green C1
Queen C1
um
doesn't feel right
before
yeah Bishop E4 looks great
Bishop C2 perhaps but then
in the worst case scenario we can do
something like
maybe taking us a bit too
we're just giving white an easy time
here I wanted to do like takes
Queen takes actually it makes perfect
sense Lawrence because after Bishop C to
Queen C2 still you don't have the idea
exactly so now now I can go yeah
is pretty bad yeah
it's bad
it's bad so again uh
I don't know he had
some very deep idea here which
apparently never materialized right I
don't know what it was
oh my gosh it was pretty obvious that
the black is not gonna take it so I
think it was like part of this
psychological warfare he's carrying
against what they say if he just didn't
quite work
for
key card yeah I uh I I don't really get
it though because
he's in such a dogfight for this you
know for for qualifying that I don't
think this is the time for psychological
warfare I think this is a time for
you know move like one C4 not weaken the
king try not to be too creative with a
guy that you know
can put you under pressure we saw it in
a lot of games already even the first
game of this particular round I had to
say I've had a great position so Hikaru
in huge trouble and if he loses this
you know he's in deep trouble he he
could really struggle
um that's right yeah he loses the match
now he does play Blue bum
tomorrow this is what I think he is
thinking and feather save plays Carlson
so I think he's thinking okay
I've got it some insurance here because
I should be blue bum but you never know
um I don't know I know okay he's still
within this game of course so I don't
think that Hikaru has given up on this
game just yet but
uh
okay Bishop F3 look at that actually
this makes sense maybe ideas to play
Queen E1 and D3
and also the queen only one is ready to
jump somewhere to G3 I just desperately
try to imagine how he he courage I'm
failing all the time but um
I guess Queenie one this has to be in
the move uh the move yes yes
feels like the move just and he has
players yes I guess that we got one I
got one yes we've got one all right so
quitting one
still a precarious position
um A4 is the move of course
and then white is going to play like
Knight C1 995
yeah but I'm not that scared somewhere
A4 Knight C1
can we go E5 or is it not a move we want
to you mean after A4 or immediately
probably after A4 yes a49 C1 E5 oh
F takes E5 Knight takes E5 for the
moment your knight is dead on C1 your
Bishop is dead on A1 I might yeah you
take Queen takes A8
I play Queen E4 next I try and occupy
the squares I can even play F5
Queen D5 Queen D5
looks like it's centralizing move yes
and this bishop might never even see the
sunlight because there's always Knight
C4 oh my goodness this is just so bad uh
yeah this is a brilliant Point Lawrence
uh A4 E5 there might be some other
choices as well but uh
I'm sure it's not the strongest but
yeah
let's let's move on maybe because okay
it just pretty difficult to watch what's
suffering here
so your suggestions where do you want to
go all right let's go let's have a look
at bluebound Carlson
all right
foreign
white is ready to Castle
Knight G3
black is going to do the same like a
slightly suffering uh it appears to be
yeah a little bit of suffering here
actually and of course
this is a very relevant game right here
because if Matthias does the
the unexpected and beats Magnus
um
the group is
wide open even Matthias can still
qualify if he wins this particular
game I think
okay Bishop B7 played by Magnus covering
the Knight
there's a there's actually a very
interesting comment in the chat all
whites are suffering I didn't notice
interesting all white colors are
suffering in this round sometimes the
scabbers except maybe of this game but
uh here white is doing pretty much all
right but all the other games why the
suffering yeah sometimes this happens
sometimes there's some weird
coincidences
uh that's very interesting okay
yeah very rare isn't it for that to
happen we saw around was it the last
round or the round before where
actually it was nearly four white winds
very close to get four white losses
would be
well it would be very very unusual
uh so okay
okay so Bishop E7 is played I guess
magnus's idea is again to play Rook A8
short Castle play A4 establish the
weaknesses here why I really like
White's position here because
it just visually looks better so yeah
Knight G3 should Castle maybe D4 E4 take
the center with potential go for the
king side attack because the bishop A1
uh potentially could with a with the
help of the knights with a cup of a pawn
Center could do some good
that's why I'm saying that why it looks
uh better but maybe it's not much
okay all right let's go to some there
somewhere with a bit more action then
and let's go back to quit our sin
against Abra setsorov never failing to
give us pure entertainment these two and
what is going what
[Music]
what are we looking at here I'm I'm
sorry but this just makes no sense yeah
I don't know
I mean
strategical point of view from I mean
Lawrence you're gonna beat me up here
right I am backing you up
from a strategical point of view you're
looking at the bishop name one right and
you're very happy where the bishop is
right and you're probably thinking why
this is gonna probably play C4 at some
point to bring the bishop in the game
so why play B for yourself it just
doesn't make any sense
yes
uh it's it's it's it's it's it's not my
I'm just not on the same level as him I
mean what can I say
I I just don't know ah you know Lawrence
maybe the idea is somehow specifically
Queen A7 idea because from a strategical
point of view it doesn't make any sense
at all maybe the big point is after C4
there's some sort of uh
shot like this looks like a this looks
like a really good Sicilian for black
right some kind of
Khan or something like that
um with with uh with a bad Bishop on D3
and pressure on F2
yeah so I don't like C4
did he place it he played C4 okay now he
he first played Bishop Beetle no no no
no oh sorry
Bishop b29 E7 but uh I mean okay uh of
course
knows what he's doing it's just I'm just
telling from strategical point of view
right you're not supposed to play B4
you're not supposed to open this bishop
and he's doing it and that's why
sometimes in chess you're making
uh weird moves because specifically in
that position it's a great choice still
that being said I don't think B4 is a
good move right it just can't be because
white is going to play C for himself and
if you really badly want to play Queen
A7 why don't you play Queen A7 right
away right so which is still a very
legit idea I'm just not sure how how B4
helps you
play Queen S7
so that's it but
I simply don't know is the answer is the
is the honest answer I don't understand
what's good they're not the reasoning
yeah they're not the reasoning why why
it had to be played
foreign
let's keep the show rolling and let's go
back to Nakamura for the safe that that
was such a such an interesting position
there has been some changes in the
Dynamics here
and it looks as though things has got a
lot better for Hikaru the bishop on E1
now has life
he's got a stable Knight on D4 there are
ideas of Queen G3 very quickly and all
kinds of pressure on the black pieces
and black king what happened looks like
he sacrificed a pawn oh I'm sorry yeah
he sacrificed the pawn so this was
exactly what we were having a look at on
this line before and Hikaru said here
you take it I mean take my Pawn at least
I'm activating the bishop I don't want
to suffer and now he activates his
pieces 95 Rook F5 and
I think Hikaru is fighting for the draw
here with all of his activity
a pawn is upon
I I don't see what he has for it
but I I I I I like his decision actually
because I think the other position was
so bad
that he had to do something
but but you're right a pawn is a pawn a
boy was a pond right and but again
Hikaru definitely is a very creative
player so to take him down just like
that it's easier said than done right
and uh I I think he probably I'm sorry
yeah no no I think please please I think
he probably uh suspects that he is uh
worse he should suspect that he's worse
but I don't think he thinks he's losing
and he probably thinks that okay I give
up my Pawn I act with my Visa as I'm
probably worse but I'm not losing that
this is one of a very important that I
can try to salvage this game because of
uh I'm leading an active defense so I
think he's doing everything right and
also for the safe is doing everything
absolutely correct
it's a brilliant Pawn sacrifice look at
this Lawrence Bishop P5 Dita X rookie 5.
yes
and now what is even there's
uh whatever I don't know I mean some
sort of an active move like Rook d8
Maybe
and uh White yes
Castle
don't forget
oh how do we know
maybe white Colin Castle maybe white
corn Castle sorry come on
by the way
I should be able to Castle no yeah I
think
I just don't know the gas castle look on
the live board he did Castle yeah I
should be able I just can't Castle I
don't know why
all right
okay
well on the live board he has so let's
just go straight there let's just bring
bring that to the uh to the main board
won't let you huh it's just not letting
me it's just not letting you know wow I
can't Castle all right
something we're gonna have to work on
but if we can you bring up the main
board and probably
that position will be yeah
just a second let's let's sort us out
okay all right while you sort that out
I'm scanning the other games pretty
level everywhere from what I can see
uh even blue balm you know maybe even
slightly better against Magnus
um
so some work for Magnus to do
yeah and the publisher
has decided to punt Harry the H Pawn
only needing a draw
all right so you want to check over uh
the game of Wesley again snip on this
year right sure let's do that all right
here we go
H5 here we go
all right up
it makes sense right like yeah I guess
H4 wreck H5 is an idea at some point you
can always bring your rook in the game
also like this
yeah absolutely
um
I love it for black I think it looks
really interesting yeah why not
yeah and you don't need to ask Jan the
Palmer Sheikh twice to make Queen H3
Knight F6
the queen in really I mean that is an
unusual Square for the queen hate it
don't get it actually
he's not gonna win no Wesley is not
going to win this yeah I think it's
quite clear I think it's quite clear
because uh he's just solely worse also
in this position uh he has no Center
uh the bishop and A4 is striking empty
it's not doing anything the knights on
d33 are beautiful the queen on H3 is
weird
uh
I don't see calcius gonna win this and
also black has ideas like Knight H5
Knight F4 maybe Rook H5 okay let's move
this way Black's position is looking
more normal if that matters and he has
extra nine minutes on the clock
wow
yes this is
this is tough this is tough to watch
um
we still can't Castle huh no I'm trying
we're trying
I'm trying to Castle okay uh
uh yeah very very bad second it's my
match
uh for
Wesley
um
let's go back there black against gretas
and quickly check in
uh because
yeah just a second well this is
this is an interesting one
so Gregerson managed to revive his
Bishop surai sort of right
right
I don't see her is not doing much right
actually this is one of those funny
moments when you wish you didn't have
the part on e4 because the pawn on e4 is
gone now this bishop is pretty strong
and you have a very nice control of the
light squares but it is there so I think
white wants to play something like
Knight H4 Knight F5 black is probably
thinking about rearranging the bishop on
E6 to extra control the light squares I
can easily see uh black taking over this
game
so uh
yes definitely I'm a bit surprised how
it's equal I mean I would I would prefer
black I would say black hole day here I
have no idea why this is equal
um
I mean it just feels like black has got
all the trumps
but maybe white is just solid enough
just to hold basically
you know look at the clock Lawrence
15 minutes versus six
speed is the young uzbeking ramsters so
yeah right approach as well probably one
right
yes
and
Rook D5 come on you have to do it if you
don't play Rook D5 I'm gonna be
disappointed well it's the classic but I
mean he will play Rook D5 I mean that's
just one question so and maybe this is
the key concept that allows yes this
cast will be there's just no other way
there's just no other way and I think
that gretelson probably played Rook D1
here the previous move the player Rook
D5 there's just no way he was targeting
the pawn on D6
so rugby five I mean this should be
blessed out
what else what else
I really don't see any other move
maybe he's doing with some order of the
moves like not H4 first and then Rook D5
yeah Rook D5 played immediately so this
is one of the most famous Maneuvers by
Digger and Petrosian uh the former world
champion uh back in the 60s uh maybe in
the 50s I don't know he used to play
this uh maneuver sacrificing The
Exchange many memorable games
uh and the idea of course is to open the
bishop so clearly gretelson has studied
the classics
oh no doubt about it
The Rook is a great block blocker
and with the light Square Bishop able to
come alive I actually don't think you're
supposed to take this Rook believe it or
not I think you're supposed to pass yeah
no I don't think that the Satora is
going to take it not here maybe he's
going to put the bishop on F7 King gate
Shader Bishop gate and then at some
point he's going to take on Diva but not
right now it's just your gut feeling you
feel there's something on those light
squares you just don't want to test that
it's just whatever do something else not
not take the Rook on D5 yeah
all right let's keep on moving uh where
else can we go
that's interesting let's see here uh
photo save let's go back there Nakamura
photo save all right of course a very
interesting battle there
and what have we got going on here so
Hikaru tried to get active
foreign
a lot of activity here right
yes yes indeed
and
well
who would you take I might be tempted to
take white here
I know I'm a
and I'm a pawn down but
Knight F4 Knight F4 is ice
yeah yeah I agree and suddenly when you
look at this position it's amazing how
the position changed right because if
you just step back after the openings
I'm just going to show you very quickly
this position what was this weirdness
uh this weirdness I mean it's quite
obvious that what is just significantly
worse the bishoplay one is disconnected
from the game and there's some light
School weaknesses Etc that's where the
C4 was such a great positional sacrifice
talked about the bishop and now you look
at the position which we have right now
I mean the Michigan C3 is great then I
don't need to have some squares The
Rookery 5 is attacking the queen uh the
king the queen on G3 is attacking the
king and uh black in return has sort of
some chaotic placement of the pieces
okay maybe still pretty good but
it starts to feel that what he has a
compensation here
definitely doesn't feel that good uh the
the the play the the peace placement as
you said um I'm not at all loving it uh
from the black perspective yeah from
Black's perspective oh yeah maybe not
Rook H6 yeah it's pretty weird
by the way I I I'm uh did he go Knight
F4
wait what
did he play Knight F4
yeah did he miss Knight F3 check
what
oh
does that actually check what
no I don't have to check
and The Rook is under attacking
are you sure so
wait I mean
and if I take
there's no discovered attack on nothing
right maybe something
okay but this is just uh Queen B7 Bishop
C5 and anything
and so I might be five yeah but I do
agree I do agree it's a bit strange
right I mean one would expect that you
would take the exchange
so 95 Queen something E6
um exchange is an exchange right like a
pawn is a pawn
but this is a huge exchange to take this
this gives you amazing I agree now the
Rooks start and and everything starts to
work I agree that that is actually a bit
surprising
but Knight F3 is a bit unusual check
yeah and he played Queen F7 immediately
but I mean
with this time on the clock you would
expect him to
to find this now he might still be doing
well but
it's not completely clear I'm not I'm
not really sure was it like a mutual
blunder
maybe it was no maybe he maybe he got a
missed it and uh
you know one thing Lawrence it's also
quite difficult to notice is that uh to
spot a combination which is not there a
move ago and it's very very difficult
because I mean you look at this position
are you even looking at Knight F3 I mean
no I mean what Knight F3 you're just not
even looking that direction your
opponent plays neither four your queen
is under attack your mindset says okay I
need to guard some weaknesses and then
you play Queen F7 so it's very easy to
miss like tactical shots like neither
tree which were not available to move
before and we have seen this happen all
the time right so but still I do believe
this is pretty obvious right
you're right okay and now H4 Bishop C7
E4 feels as though
you know black is going backwards here
somehow
feels
very very uh negative
by fedasev and Hikaru now with a grip on
some squares and now it's coming to D5
this is
night and day from what we saw just a
few moves ago what an incredible
recovery
yeah definitely white is having a full
compensation here I wouldn't really say
that what is better because wow that is
really passive here I was the ship
Bishop D I mean what are we watching
here this is just so negative
I don't like any of it
so I guess he wants to play G6
and if I play 95
exactly
G6
Ah that's his idea he wants to trap The
Rook Rook F2 is Bishop B6 oh wait
there's Knight of six ideas no wait
there's no notifications
Rook of two Bishop B6 just with the
exchange because not of success queen of
sex so you can't do that you can't take
the queen
so maybe his big idea is Rook F4 and
then could be some
I don't know what F5
Rook takes F5
I was looking at some Queen A7 ideas but
I guess it's a engine is like
yeah they're looking at
oh it's ridiculous
I don't know what's the idea
this must be the idea I mean try to uh
Play Jesus better again let's let's
check this so 95 G6 and Rooker 4. I
don't like this Bundy yet anymore
because uh had it been standing on B6 C5
at least I see something what's it doing
there
okay
very very very strange
meanwhile let's go to Grace arson
against
have to set her off
how is is the Icelandic Grandmaster
going to score even just one
point he's lost five in a row
and his position
no you mean he gave up that exchange but
what a fantastic version he did take
okay but he just found a way to
yeah uh this move
he did take it I mean you know wow 96
not 95 okay that's a bit
strange
and if so
E4 cutting the pieces was really good
yeah now you don't have the kind of
counts play you want
feels feels good for black
yeah this is definitely great for black
because now you have nothing for the
exchange okay maybe we could argue that
white has enough compensation but again
to remind you dear viewers the
tournament system this is like a giant
Tournament of double round Robins at the
group stage right now the best will
qualify for The Knockout stages and
greterson lost the previous game this
means he has to win this one so for up
the sator of drop over there so okay
fine let's make a draw
I I think that if letters would offer a
draw I think of the Sutra we just agree
right so he wins the mini match he gets
two points
and he solidifies his leading tournament
so that's why it's pretty much bad news
for why he has to win this
talking of bad news why
I tell you what
Wesley so has not been
present for the past two games look at
the state of his position here piece
down
and
I don't know it looks
looks losing to me
oh wow look
have a look at this one
where's this piece
sorry there's uh I'm looking where's his
piece I mean there's a couple of Pawns
there's a bishop on A8
a knight on F6 so right right I'm just
trying to figure out where his piece
went missing
ah okay he probably sacked it because
his position was so bad that he felt
like he needed to to have some
Liberation but this position is
is not good I mean you're losing
if he trades Queens that's it and also
Lawrence also here is this exactly the
same situation as in the previous uh
matchup of the satorf against graterson
because again Wesley needs to win this
he needs to win this and maybe actually
for him losing this could be pretty much
over because he loses to his direct
competitor to qualify for The Knockout
tournament
is crushing everybody he goes 100 so he
loses to his direct competitor for the
second play so it's going to be very
very tough for the American Grandmaster
try to still reach The Knockout phase
and defend his title
correct
blue bum Carlson is a relatively mild
Affair some strange positioning of the
knights but
we go there we can have a quick look
it's it will certainly I mean it's not
the most uh
adrenaline inducing
uh uh position that's for sure
but uh we can have a quick look
yep I would play D4 here as white that's
for sure
uh to try and to try and push D5
and Knight C5 as well is also an idea
and D4 is played yeah dread move
yeah it feels like feels like a natural
movement as you said Knight C5 maybe
Magnus is is actually feeling a bit of
pressure here
maybe Magnus is feeling just a little
bit of pressure
yeah I guess he has to play Knight A6
look he needs to stop Knight C5
um D5 is also an idea
oh wait Knight H6 I just dropped the
point on A5 yeah you can't go Knight A6
I like D5
I like this
uh yes it's going D5 here exactly
D5
right and if I play 95 ah 95 just take
one in four probably
and if I take it can I ah you can't
really play CDX right I guess there's
some background issues yeah
nice cp6 looks very bad
engine says let's see look at this
thing yeah but from afar this looks so
bad
it's nothing
I mean I would probably let you take
something five
and then you have weakness on yeah this
looks very tricky now this looks this
looks very very tricky
I think Magnus is genuinely worried here
I think Magnus is thinking yeah he
should be worried we we don't enter
propositions like the engine
just a second now let me uh
oh wait I lost it
um The Game's gone
okay okay let's let's let's check
another another one yeah
so maybe let's go to hikaru's game
against okay
um
Vladimir for the safe
okay
all right
foreign
yeah let's let's actually have a bird's
eye view of things
let's get a close-up of these guys uh
Carlson
and blue balm
well uh if you're looking at the uh blue
bombs position like we already discussed
it appears to be that he's Lively
pressing
and then we look at uh hikaru's game
against fare Seth um I would actually go
as far and say there's just no way
Hikaru is going to lose this it's
amazing how we come to this because this
Knight on the E5 is so strong that if
somebody comes play the second feeling
it's only black
despite the fact it's equal position
Wesley is unrecognizable today
completely I don't know
so Wesley completely unrecognizable
today
yeah
suffering so I think it's uh pretty much
again psychology all over uh great
person is suffering from the previous
games missed win and Wesley is suffering
because of previous games uh unfortunate
attempt to Castle short
which was
yeah pretty bad yeah so
I think we can go to a game now uh can
we can we go to
which one
it's a tough one let's go to Nepal
machine let's just see how he decides to
do this one
suppose she doesn't even need to win
this
uh that's the greatest problem that
Wesley has so he can just plays some
combos I think of course the publish is
gonna try to play for the win he doesn't
need any stress he doesn't need to prove
anything and if he's gonna find a force
draw I'm pretty sure he's Gonna Take It
so why why go for something
there's no extra points for the small
points right as far as I know it's just
two points for the yeah for the victory
yeah he just needs a draw to win this
match just make a draw okay maybe maybe
then in the long run right you calculate
that uh maybe Wesley
oh wait but they already played it
didn't they no I I
don't think the long run matches if they
would meet again if they would meet
again that maybe it would matter really
what was the result of the first mini
match
I I think I think that uh nepomish is
simply uh from the position of strength
if he can he's going to make a draw but
of course he's going to try to play for
me right
Abdu said sort of closing in on that
Victory what a horrible
day it's been for gretas and just
had his chance
couldn't make it work and now he's just
close to oh well this is
this is just losing you're in exchange
down your king is wide open
uh
just not not really too much to talk
about here
it's just
yeah
you know immediately over basically
now our cage Forest killing of course
glad there's some Castle play it out and
also you can see in the clock one minute
against 13.
but he has got the five minutes already
right so
ah
so I'm not really sure though
not totally sure about that
so G3 is played
to stop yeah
um
okay still some work to do
yeah but I I think even something like
Rook effects rookie year the blood
pressure against the pawn on E3 makes
perfect sense
uh as long as black keeps an eye on some
97 checks oh wait by the way oh it
doesn't work Rook of Fate I was thinking
Queenie for
some funny ideas 97 King H7 rook f8 and
if only I could play Knight G6 on Rook
HH Checkmate but of course
we need to Oakland H5 I'll just seals
the deal yeah
so no surprises here
no uh do we which which game do we
select now I think we go to Carlson
because he had that interesting moment
and he and he went for D6 instead of D5
he went for D6 instead of D5
so this was after D4 D6 yeah and he's
managed to get some stability but he's
still worse in my opinion
he's still worse
I don't know
what do you think
I don't know I I go back to this
position and uh
I would be thinking if
blow them really hard to push D5 because
I see the pawn on C6 as a weakness
so essentially what he does after
playing D5 he trades it he trades a
weakness
he opens the C file which he can't
really use there's an atom on C4 but
apparently he was maybe he was throwing
or bluffing with the idea that there's
going to be Knight B6 and Magnus just
cold-bloodedly calculated there's
nothing there's just nothing and maybe
that was part of uh blue bombs idea that
Knight B6 is going to work and then he
realized oh my goodness it just kind of
doesn't work and that's why he played
this 97 I'm not so sure that this is
what he wanted to be honest because if
you don't go there then just play
something else I'm going to try to press
the pawn on C6 maybe play I don't know
Knight D3 with the E5 try to get the C5
Square the 194 is pretty sad
but
it's a pretty pretty tough to tell
because still this is a rapid game and
you have to make those decisions very
quick
so
among this is usually is doing marvelous
things
Magnus doing Magnus things
how often we've heard it
yet we still can't work out how to do it
ourselves
uh back to Nakamura finna save let's why
not and all right save maybe made a
little bit of progress got in the F5
break I like it trying to get a bit of
breathing room for his pieces
I do like it
I'm trying to go play the porn count I I
think black just lost his extra Pawn
so I think it was here
G3 and for the sake of sacrificed upon
he gave up the phone
that just launched The Rook
and went for a counter-attack yeah but I
like it
and now it's not so clear
I guess the threat is just like King G7
and F4 at some point and try to capture
this Rook this Rook on H6 is suddenly in
a world of pain he carried down to four
minutes
uh they've passed 31 move marks so they
will be getting more time
and if I play H5 what happens
nothing happens right
Bishop G5 our Bishop G5 is real G6 so
Queen G6
I tried I'm I'm I'm no but here I take
one GC okay okay yeah no no Rook G6 is
97 but I tried to figure out yeah
rookie four yeah yeah it's not applyable
line I was just trying to uh try to to
make this work this H5 so H5 is not an
idea there's also Queen A7 ID at some
point oops
Queen H7
wow
Rook F7 Queen B8 rook f8 and repeat that
would be repeat
that would be a cute repeat and now I
play H5
wow all right I I don't understand a
thing so the bar just barges drops and
and uh increases but I think Queen A7
looks perfectly legit right so
I'm not sure what what what black is
supposed to do against that I mean uh
Rook F7 looks normal
maybe there's something else
so what do you do after Queen A7 I'm not
sure I'm not sure
I could go Queen F7
and that's actually a very good point
and now we're still trying to play King
G7 trapped exactly or queen G7 so you
might have to take yeah by the way is on
the board
queen queen F7 here
feels like a tidy uh he went brick F7 we
could get that repeat
we could get that repeat if higara wants
it because why should he want it because
um he's playing with white he managed to
climb from a terrible position right
after the opening he's ahead on the
clock oh wait he's not on the head Below
on the clock no he's not no he's not
okay so maybe then he wants it I don't
think so though he's gonna try to push
it
he could never repeat it and then make a
Content out of it
he has to play
whoa what
Ruby said rookie five oh
he missed xf5 he missed it he blundered
Rook F5
yeah if you missed something like this
that's it that's it you miss it so for
the safe side here was either x 25 Queen
D5 this is impossible he simply
blundered rookie five wow now Knight F6
check is a huge thread what about Genji
seven wait it's still not over
okay so there's something seven there's
something strong here
something really strong I don't see it
yet
I don't test what about Knight F6 anyway
because Bishop takes F6 Queen h8 will be
made
oh
that's the little shot oh goodness oh my
goodness so maybe this is what he missed
actually maybe he saw him maybe he saw
it maybe this is the only mode which
actually wins for white
and now Rook H7 Rook HH Rook H7 now this
is pretty bizarre way to connect the
Rooks but it works right
and I'm pretty sure about now for the
safe has realized that I mean usually
it's very quick
um
I I think that you probably agree on
this Lawrence is that when you when you
play it normally and you press the clock
that's the moment when you see oh yeah
always that's the moment you press the
clock yes yeah that's oh oh there's this
it's just like a sudden Revelation right
that you immediately see things which
you could not see before making
physically the move
I don't know how to call it
wow
so
Hikaru is going to win this after an
opening let me just show it to you after
this opening
after
this possession
with the bishpate one
which is just incredible I mean how does
it do it
oh it is amazing
just a magician
yeah
[Music]
um
yeah I've just had sort of completely
winning now an information easy win
and this one looks like it's going to be
an easy win as well
and this also means that it's a major
blow for the safe chances to qualifa for
The Knockout stage because
Hikaru is the leader right of the group
and this means essentially for for the
save that he has to beat Magnus
uh which might be still not be enough
so
yes
it's going to be a big day tomorrow
it's going to be a huge day
um
I think that's still nothing fair to say
have just can't make a move he's he's
too shocked that he blundered this
I think right I think he just probably
already realized Genji sevens Rook H5
which is amazing tactics now he's just
trying to come up with some unexpected
resource but of course Hikaru also is
not just sitting and waiting and he's
also cork letting all the potential
follow-ups that feather sieve could do
maybe what about Rook D5 here oh C3
there you go so I was looking at Rook D5
here Rook D5
why
ah really five you just take it and the
best yet is unprotected yeah you can't
do it
why can't I just take this Pawn DC
yeah I think
just say okay and what I'll just take a
pawn thanks very much
yeah it makes perfect sense I yeah don't
really see how it changes
anything at all the pawn on dito Pawn on
C4 don't matter unless it weakens the
king for some checks but yeah the bars
mercilessly saying there's nothing
do we watch this until the end uh by the
way there's a result of the satorophy
has managed to win against Waterson so
that is official yeah a miserable day
for gratson who had his moment
but with that loss since the first round
where he drew with Wesley so has lost
six games consecutively
when you play with the big boys
sometimes you get a beating uh
uh oh this game here let's go we've had
some action so Queen B6 okay fair to
save trying to manufacture something
because this Rook on H6 is still
yeah but if you go Rook there aren't you
running into some Queen B1 oh yeah yeah
Perpetual check that's what I wanted to
say it's a Perpetual check
s
they're not helping you at all it should
be Perpetual Chuck yeah right it's a
pretty great idea
so for the save came up came up with
something so don't look at the bar he
came up with something but essentially
okay it comes down to this he's done
exchange down upon oh wait how many
pawns two points
yeah he needs to find something but
while we'll stir on this let's go
straight to the Magnus Carlson game
because is Matthias bluebaum going to
pull off an upset
against the world champion
possibly
no I
you know I don't think so no there's D5
D5 is paid three markers is never going
to lose this
uh D5 for space three yeah
ah I missed that yeah so maybe D5 93
Bishop A3 95 95 Rook D5 Bishop E4 monk
this is trying to evaluate because he
tried to win this and we see that uh on
the camera wait a second is a draw so he
didn't find a way
what
wow wait wait wait wait wait how is how
it's a draw
well now after Rook G5 he just takes
takes Queen B1 and it's just Perpetual
right
okay let's we just jump back to that
game a bit later but it just didn't look
like it's a drawing I don't know what
happened there
very very strange just as feder safe was
already done I mean the game was lost
hikarik had done everything black
blunder suddenly you draw
I I
don't get yeah
me neither and the position that you
said in the Carlton game has appeared on
the board
um
as you said you don't think Magnus ever
loses this
no Magnus is pushing for the win so the
194 is disconnected so Among Us is
saying listen you're not gonna need for
disconnected opponent of the five is
slightly weak
so he's trying to make something happen
here and also for Magnus this is very
important because if he doesn't win this
this means this matches uh tied right
it's just one one yes so it's not enough
and uh he's racing with Hikaru although
he encourages you but I don't think he
knows that
okay let's go let's have a look here
blue bum only probably like 15 seconds
left on the clock if 94 you've got Rook
F takes F5 he just wonder that you could
see yeah you could see from the body
language he realized that 94 is numb
he's like what what did righteousness
unbelievable Magnus Carlson
finding another trick five seconds oh
Rook of five jack how many moves is it
all right and he's decided to go for the
double Rook ending and as we say in
French
[Music]
is awaiting
the German Grandmaster this is a
position of your worst nightmares Pawn
down double Rook ending no time against
arguably the greatest end game player of
all time might be still a draw by the
way
that's another question it's very
difficult it's very difficult but he
could have played pretty much uh saving
him now he's down upon again again in
the mind it's the
yeah it's just it's the it's what
happened before right and sometimes it's
not easy to get rid of that so that's
why I really admire players who are just
not thinking about what happened before
and they're just moving on I I could
never do that I always carry it with me
and
uh
would give six
okay
so the critical moment here very quickly
I'm gonna have a peek I'm just looking
at what's happening with Wesley so games
against yamne promise she I think that
oh wow I think that they
could be a draw I mean the bomb machine
there's no way he's going to lose this
so pretty clear that nipomino she
secures the victory against Wesley so as
it was predicted
so this game is still wide open meaning
either a draw or Magnus wins
yes
let's stay with this one
is
increment gonna be able to save this
very difficult
very difficult so normally three pawns
against two
and rookiech it's a draw so that's why
Magnus is desperately gonna try to keep
the pawn on A5 alive and he's going to
try to keep both Rooks alive I think he
should do it not try to trade it he
traded he did
yeah but I think he's gonna just bring
the king in now King F6 precisely
and Rook a six King F5
and then you go King E4 uh he wants King
F5 Rook H6 this is
King E5
so he's just straight to the B3 Pawn
now you can just take Rook takes B3 Rook
H5 F6
sure if this is winning at all
I'm not sure at all
so if I play rookie chat okay no this is
good Rook h8 okay I put my Pawn on the
third right
I guess right okay eight A3 and the King
runs the B2 right
um dindi foreign
let's see
oh he left he he gave a check that looks
unnecessary ghgh King C3 H5 King B2 this
looks or King C3 immediately looks like
black is winning
I'm not sure why the check was necessary
I mean my gut instinct says this should
be winning
ah now he wants to calculate whether the
rook and no but he already has the king
Cuts really simple yeah yeah that is
winning the the king is too far away and
uh by now I think already he uh blue
watches realized he's completely
mistaken
A2 yeah Rook A5 King B2
fairly simple end game
Champion yeah King he just shows you to
Rook A3 yeah he has to take take King G2
he'll play
and then you just keep the king card and
oh and Devastation on the face of
Matthias blue balm
I mean he did it himself right I mean he
was doing all right for most of the part
of the game and uh Marcus just used the
chances
are pretty painful but that's what it is
I mean the world champion doesn't
forgive you any mistakes
so G5 you can't play yeah the king comes
closer yeah this is it
yeah
that's what the pain looks like
wow
yeah no problem she ended up winning
that game by the way so he didn't even
draw it he ended up winning and a
massive win there for Magnus Carlsen to
take
the second match when
really Matisse bluebound will be kicking
himself
for not at least drawing he had a good
position out of the opening his middle
game is okay but he blundered a tactic
furious with himself as he storms out of
the playing Hall
I know that feeling too well
right all of us we have been there
all right so you know wait a minute
let's
wait wait too many times Magnus Carlson
leaving now uh should be happy he's now
got a great position in his group let's
quickly look at the results
uh of uh the second uh match the second
match today Matthias bluebellum losing
to minus Carlson one all just four draws
in Nakamura for to say four incredible
fights but all draws wild wacky draws
Wesley so just he he had an accident
today he just didn't turn up yeah no
problem is he winning the match there
and Abdul saturov eating gratasan after
gratasan couldn't recover
psychologically from a great position
and that means the groups are as follows
in group a well we haven't I beg your
understandings I should say are as
follows uh
Abdullah of on eight points that might
need to be changed because he's on seven
and a half out of eight so these might
not be
completely accurate but
oh
I beg your poems two points for win it
is correct eight points for abdisator of
and they're publishing now with daylight
uh versus Wesley so gratasan not really
performing and in group b it is tied at
the top Carlson and Nakamura are sharing
the lead with six points but better save
he's gonna need a miracle tomorrow's
playing against Magnus Carlson he's
gonna have to beat Magnus uh at least
once
to have a chance of qualifying tomorrow
is the final group matches day
same time same place it's been a wild
wacky day as you would expect
with Fisher random chess highs lows
otters it's been
I mean
I've been there have been so many
moments today where I've been just
asking what what what just happened it's
very confusing but very yes sometimes
sometimes this happens but um yeah a bit
a bit strange from a strategical point
of view also this uh very strange draw
agreement of Hikaru nakumar against
Vladimir for the safe you know I really
wanted to check it because there was
something that
I just couldn't understand how hikara
managed to agree to a draw in the in the
final position against like limit for
the safe and here
uh if we could pull it up uh here Hikaru
played Rook G5 which was quite
surprisingly played the draw and
apparently I mean i s uh according to
the mighty engines png2 was the move to
be played and here black has no
Perpetual check and the big point is
after King G7 now you have this very
beautiful Rook G5 so by doing this you
secure the rook in H6 oh wow because
Rook G5 is H takes and after Bishop
takes in G5 you simply play I guess at
some point Queen hhk right so
alternatively Hikaru here I guess could
have played also H5 which also looked
pretty logical H5 and then threatened to
take on G6 so that's why I slightly
didn't understand this through G5 at all
but
a bit strange misstep by
hikarp
all right let's take a look at
tomorrow's matches then
we've got Wesley so against Cresson uh
it's going to be critical for Wesley to
win both of those Jana publishi against
uh nordebec address of that that has got
the makings of a firecracker that really
will be an exciting match Nakamura
against bluebound well Hikaru has to try
to win both matches there Federal Sav
Carlson that one is going to be also
very very interesting too
creative players fair to save as well so
resourceful I've been impressed with him
disappointed with him
um I've had all the emotions with
Felicia today guys it's been an absolute
pleasure remember to check out
oh and then there's one more round of
matches I beg your pardon then then of
course
we've got Carlson Nakamura in round 60.
yes they played each other today twice
tomorrow's not the same Carlson Nakamura
for all the marbles tomorrow could
decide who goes through in that group uh
blue band for to save abuccessor of so
we're Tarzan Nippon machine what a day
we've got tomorrow to see who advances
artists has been great everybody thank
you so much for joining us do remember
to check out uh Brave uh this broadcast
has uh been uh broadcast by chess.com of
course but brought to you by Brave
uh private browsing so much more go and
check them out uh it's brave.com forward
slash chess
and do bear in mind that also the
women's candidates tournament
is currently taking place and we've got
coverage of that as well some of the top
women players in the world
participating do check that out
I'm out of breath I don't know about you
artists I need I need a breather
um I mean it's been a very long day and
actually since we said it at the start I
was at the last month we placed uh a
replace Robert who is feeling slightly
under the weather so we wish Robert the
best of luck to recover so he's gonna be
back in one of your favorite
commentators
to provide action for the official just
random from me I say goodbye it was an
absolute pleasure to be here and I hope
you enjoyed it and come back tomorrow
watching the uh the size of day of the
group matches and uh it's gonna be fun
all right see you take care guys see you
tomorrow
goodbye
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign